da bin ich leute heute ist es soweit kubornitis kubornitis stream
oder oder auch kubanitis oder kubanitis oder kubanitis oder was auch immer
wir sind cool wir sprechen ja auch ubuntu nicht ubuntu aus sondern jubantu also sagen wir natürlich
auch eindeutig auch kubanitis kubanitis das wird übrigens heute als übrigens nicht sponsored bei
hetzen oder so wir machen heute die sachen noch lokal und es wird erst mal auch nur horizontal
skaliert heute ich weiß ich weiß das ist eigentlich nicht das performer mindset wie heißt das
doch performer mindset oder wie heißt das shit high performer halt das nicht das high performer
mindset es wird heute auch nicht der einzige stream sein dazu weil da gibt es einiges das
ist eine fass ohne boden und es ist jetzt auch nicht so als bin ich zum aktuellen zeitpunkt
der krasseste kubanitis experte den es auf diesem planeten gibt ich habe damit schon was gemacht ich
habe die letzten tage auch so ein bisschen noch um probiert und ich habe schon mal die deployment
jammel gemacht und dann was zum laufen gebracht und also ganz komplett ahnungslos bin ich nicht
aber ich bin jetzt nicht der der der krasseste profi ever jetzt jetzt aber was machen wir
ein bisschen ahnung haben verstehe nicht was ihr meint mit skalieren das wirst du dann im laufe
des films sehen was mit skalieren gemeint ist da wird hyperscaled wird da da kann man
richtig schöne tolle cloud buzzwords draus machen die hyperscalenden cloud native container
infrastructure s keine ahnung ja fast jeden tag wenn ich nicht streben abends
mit den mit den gleichen leuten wieder näher ich bin auch am spiel ich habe gesehen du bist
nicht über level 11 rausgekommen nicht so ging nicht so weit gachi roll war aber während
der stream anläuft leute ich mache mal meine vm an wobei wir heute beim cool aussprechen
sind ich mache meine vm an und ich mache mal ein update bevor wir jetzt hier großen großen
kubernetes stellt man ja also leute wir gucken uns das wir gucken uns das alles an also das wird
jetzt nicht also wenn ihr jetzt erwartet wir machen jetzt hier kubernetes tutorial wie sagt
man so schön from zero to hero wenn man cool sein will dann nennt man das sowas das machen
wir nicht also ich erkläre euch ein bisschen was und ich zeige euch auch ein bisschen was und wir
probieren ein paar sachen aus aber die sinn dieser streams ist ja auch einmal dass ich euch was
zeigen kann und auch dass ich selbst besser kann das ist ja immer so eins eins ich meine ich mache
meistens nicht sachen wo ich komplett planlos bin aber wenn man die dann noch mal erklären
muss dann ist natürlich immer ein bisschen schwieriger versteht selbst besser bei patrick
horizontal skalieren ist doch mehrere maschinen hochfahren können zum skalieren oder vertikal
ist mehrere leitungen freigeben ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sicher ich glaube
horizontal skalieren ist mehrere mehrere potts starten und vertikal skalieren ist mehrere notes
hinzufügen nee keine ahnung bin ich bin ich so im hyper hyper scaler high performance mindset
ach du hast recht genau horizontal ja ja ne ne stimmt doch mehr leistung mehr leistung
ist ja im prinzip mehrere notes hinzufügen wobei du auch du musst gleichzeitig du musst
gleichzeitig ein bisschen vertikal skalieren dass du besser horizontal skalieren kannst oder
glaube da müssen wir mal eben business coach fragen der uns das erklärt wie das wie das
richtig funktioniert wir skalieren prinzipiell nur diagonal korrekt das ist richtig das haben
wir schon vor eine weile festgestellt dass für uns diagonal skalieren das beste ist dann musst
du dich nicht mit mehr mit so komischen nupp kack abgeben wie ob das jetzt vertikal oder
horizontal oder y y axel x axel z axel wir wir machen wir skalieren diagonal dreidimensional
also in alle drei dimensionen wird skaliert du brauchst mindestens fünf kubernetes cluster
daheim dass du dass du dem kerle auf youtube konkurrenz machen kannst wir skalieren sogar
runter das ist richtig wir skalieren tatsächlich heute auch runter wir skalieren mal container
von 8 auf 4 zurück und so was so ich war mal kurz bevor es richtig los geht aber kurz den
ganzen shit hier zu das haben wir hier noch swelt zeug alles weg ich war mal kurz ein update und
dann starte ich mal die vm neu dass es auch was wird hier dass wir top aktuelles kubernetes
machen können orthogonales skalierung was kommt man was kommt dann als als nächstes
parallelogramm skalierung relativistische skalierung hätte ich noch zu bieten dann
skalieren wir nicht nur in alle raum dimensionen sondern auch zeitlich was was haltet denn davon
dass wer kann das bild weg was wird moment was so warum kompiliert er gerade in den shit was
macht er da 7 zipp ich habe was viel ich zeige euch mal kurz was bevor wir kubernetes anfangen
ich habe was was ein cooles projekt auf github gefunden wenn man keinen bock auf 7 7 zipp
gedöns hat unter linux denn sich pzip das ist das macht alle möglichen formate unter anderem
auch 7 zipp und und es hat ein gui dabei einfach 8 zipp nehmen ja das ist schon ganz schön 6 hat
ich habe ich ok leute ich ich muss mal kurz was zum ich muss mal kurz 7 zipp entfernen
so und dann zeige ich euch mal was wir heute vor haben beziehungsweise was ansteht das ist vielleicht
nicht das alte 7 zipp näher so alt ist es nicht ist es last week geabdeut updated oder doch was
sind die letzte version 9.1 ist doch gut alles also gar für die ganzen qt qt chats chatter
also ich wollte noch ein update machen gut lassen wir den erst mal updateen also um was
geht es heute ich versuche jetzt mal so ganz grob mal auszuholen ja erinnert sich noch
einer an zipp drives zipp drives die hat mit zipp an sicher nichts zu tun das war eher so
halt das zipp so weiß gar nicht warum die so heißen vom geräusche oder so zipp drive ja
jomi gar zipp drive da wurde nix gezippt immer eine 100 mb diskette war damals schon richtig
krasser shit wenn die normalen disketten hatten wie viel und 1,44 mb oder 1,2 ich glaube es gab
drei disketten 800k 1,2 und 1,44 oder so was gär war es gab war das nicht so nee 3,4 gab es
nicht das wäre gut vielleicht später mal aber ich kenne also die 1,44 waren glaube ich die verbreitetsten
wisst ihr dass ich mich da dass ich mir damals wieder krasse heckermann vorgekommen bin ich
habe alte disketten vom amiga genommen das waren ja auch so floppy floppy disk floppy disk und dann
habe ich die in meinen pc laufwerk reingesteckt und dort unter windows rechts drauf geklickt und
gesagt formatieren und dann hatte ich auf einmal ganz viele leere disketten weil ich die amiga
dinger recycelt habe und da habe ich mich richtig geil gesagt mann bin ich bin ich geiler hier
heckermann ich habe quasi disketten aus dem nichts erschaffen dabei waren das ja ganz normale floppy
das halt für den amiga das habe ich nicht habe ich damals nicht gecheckt also ja amiga gescaled
genau so update ist durch update ist durch ich glaube es war ein kernel update dabei
deswegen reboote ich mal 5x dankeschön für den sub ich habe oben übrigens glaube ich noch ein
übersehen stripes hat wieder subscrib poggers danke für die subs leute so dann starten wir
mal das verdammte spiel weg damit firefox starten terminal starten und jetzt kann kubernetes
kubernetes kubernetes weiter kein bock auf krasse giga chat aussprache jetzt können wir damit
anfangen das ketten war das stimmt das ketten war schon cool dass sie der klick zu dieses klick
dieses hatte schon was nutzt du zsh ja mache ich und wenn ja welches theme ist das das ist gar
kein theme das ist also du meinst jetzt mein termin oder wirklich hier den prompt von der
shell ich vermute mal weil du zell hast was meinst du den prompt also der prompt ist starship allerdings
ein custom meister ein custom meister ein custom meister starship prompt wenn du den prompt sehen
willst gehst du hierhin auf wubblers dot files config starship und da siehst du das ich habe
den base prompt genommen von starship du musst übrigens noch sagen ob du wirklich shell oder
terminal meinst weil terminal ist anders so und ich habe dieses preset genommen von starship
pastel powerline was wiederum selbst auf m365 princess basiert das habe ich genommen und
habe ein paar custom ist sachen angepasst ja zum beispiel habe ich die schrift gemacht wie
mein hintergrund ich habe hinzugefügt dass wenn man in ein dotnet projekt geht die versionen da
stehen und so was ich habe es auch zweizeilig gemacht weil ich zweizeilige prompt persönlich
viel besser finde als einzeilige prompt ja aber es ist etwas ist das hier aber angepasst und du
kannst findest das hier ach du kacke das ist wild ja das ist das ist aber wahrscheinlich noch
neuer oder fast so alt wie unsere kobold geschichten die bei uns laufen wo ich mich
auch immer frage wo finden die immer noch leute die den kram können wir zeit wird zeit für linux
upgrade und dann das ganze einfach in free doors laufen lassen oder oder oder noch besser
wein im docker container im container weiß gar ob das gescheit funktioniert ja warum eigentlich
nicht ja aber das will man ja wahrscheinlich nicht weil man so altes zeug hat dass es stabil
läuft ob das mit wein dann unter den noch so gut ist das weiß ich ja nicht also was machen wir
heute wo fange ich denn jetzt am besten an leute wo fangen wir am besten an
serverschrank 24 wieso klingt auch ganz normal anbieter hört sich halt bisschen old school an
aber warum warum nicht klickt auch klickt auch ganz normal
erst mal ob kubernetes native stellt oder mini cube zum ausprobieren reicht das lokal voll und
ganz ach ja ich weiß wo ich anfangen ich weiß wo ich anfangen und zwar das bis heute nicht der
einzige kubernetes stream und zwar wir machen da mehrere ich weiß nicht inwieweit da bin ich
wieder unschuldig weiß ich inwieweit das alles so aufeinander aufbauen wird wahrscheinlich
kein raspberry pi cluster wahrscheinlich schon in gewisser weise wir machen aber nicht immer so
exakt die gleichen beispiel und zwar also wir brauchen mehrere wir brauchen mehrere streams
jena es hängt auch ein bisschen davon ab wie weit wir den einzelnen streams kommen aber es
wird auf jeden fall auch aus praktischen gründen mehrere streams geben das erste ist wir setzen
uns damit lokal mal ein bisschen auseinander wir müssen ja nicht gleich in die cloud in der
cloud irgendwas bauen das nächste ist wir gucken uns google cloud kubernetes an warum
gucken uns google cloud kubernetes an weil dort wo ich am ersten april anfangen zu arbeiten die
alle google cloud verwenden ich weiß nicht warum das sind die einzigen die ich kenne die google
cloud benutzen aktuell wo ich bin ist es ist es quasi fast nur ausschließlich er ich habe
schon ein bisschen was mit aws nee ich fasse nicht mit aws schon ein bisschen was privat gemacht mit
google und mit aws würde ich sagen aber abstand am wenigsten aber ich kenne außerdem niemand der
im professionellen umfeld google cloud verwendet gibt es allerdings genug nur weil ich keine kenne
heißt das nix weil ganz einfach ich kenne nicht so viele leden von innen die paar handvoll da die
ich gesehen habe die haben keine google cloud verwendet gut es heißt ja nichts erfolgreich
ist es trotzdem und ich habe mir ein paar videos angeguckt und angeblich ist das dieses autopilot
kubernetes management feature von der google cloud wohl für diesen anwendungszweck am besten dann
betreibst du nämlich gar kein kubernetes cluster mehr selbst in der google cloud sondern kannst
direkt pots deployen und die scaling und managen das für dich aber natürlich machen wir damit
nicht fangen wir damit nicht gleich an weil das ist ja langweilig müssen erstmal ein bisschen so
die grundlagen uns angucken dass man weiß wie das funktioniert weil nur was man mal von hand
zumindest ich so ein bisschen selbst angeguckt hat blickt man dann auch durch was man besser
sein lassen sollte ja deswegen gibt es mehrere streams wir machen wir wir gucken uns jetzt erst
mal wir gucken uns jetzt erst mal das ganze lokal an da machen wir mal so ein setup aus irgendwie
so einem 5 5 pots als application server mit einem load balancer und einem ssl zertifikat
oder so mit ingress controller davor wir holen uns auch echte let's encrypt zertifikate über
let's encrypt also echte echte ssl zertifikate über let's encrypt mit zert manager und was
wollen wir sonst noch wir machen den lokalen registry für container images und konfigurieren
halt das deployment und den service gucken uns das alles mal ein bisschen an ist der moogame
dankeschön für den snap was hältst du von IT zertifikat kommt ein bisschen auf die zertifikate
an aber allgemein gesagt nicht ganz so viel ja ich würde sagen wir fangen mal relativ easy an
achja und übrigens ich habe schon ein bisschen was vorbereitet wo ich abgucken kann also das
ist jetzt nicht fix und fertig aber ich habe mir so ein paar kleine snippets raus kopiert falls ich
jetzt im stream nicht direkt drauf komme weil alles auf den kopf weiß ich da auch nicht was hältst
du von lpix also das was ich bisher gesehen habe sah sehr nach man pages auswendig lernen aus aber
kann auch kann mich auch täuschen wir verwenden kein windows server doch klar
ich mache immer windows server windows server ist eindeutig die überlegene technologie deswegen
läuft ja auch 90 prozent des internets auf linux guck hier ja was sonst verstehe ich auch die
frage gar nicht was denn sonst gibt es noch was anderes windows server und powershell und iis
auf final auf was auf final ist gerade irgendwas ich habe überhaupt nichts mitgekriegt cs go ist
gerade glaube ich also wenn die windows server skalieren bist du nicht arm wenn die oracle
datenbanken skalieren dann bist du arm wobei ne ne das stimmt nicht wir können es anders machen
wenn die windows server skalieren bist du arm wenn die oracle datenbanken skalieren da kannst
du gleich insolvenz anmelden
das war das problem dass frisch arsch nicht rein copy pasten konntest in der vm ne das problem habe
ich nicht weil ich weiß was ich machen muss um das problem zu fixen jetzt ist nur die frage
möchtest du auch wissen wie man das problem fixt was muss man denn machen also die
grundvoraussetzung ist schon mal prime zu prime zu bleiben das ist schon mal essentiell und dann
zeige ich dir auch dass du gtk mm oder wie das heißt installieren muss das da musst du installieren
und dann funktioniert probier mal aus das musst du installieren und dann startet die kiste am
besten mal neu oder oder den system system d service neu starten den hast ja bestimmt
e gestartet und so was aber das ding musste installieren diese library ist pflicht sonst
funktioniert copy und paste nicht warum das keine dependency ist und warum das nirgends wo steht ich
habe keine ahnung aber du brauchst diese library sonst geht kommen paste nicht gtk mm3 warum weiß
nur vm wer so also wir uns jetzt mal hier das kubernetes kubernetes vielleicht aber was sagen
die denn was sagen die denn selbst ja das das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut ich wollte sagen
kubernetes ist ein tool zur container orchestrierung aber das sagen sie ja selbst also für alle was
genau wird heute mit kubernetes gemacht also erst mal erkläre ich kurz was kubernetes ist kubernetes
ist quasi so was wie docker nur geklastert und mit wie wir klären ist am besten es ist es ist
so was wie docker nur verteilt über mehrere server ich glaube das kann man eigentlich am besten
glaube das umschreibt eigentlich am ehesten ne du kannst doch einen server nehmen du kannst
doch ein server nehmen aber für ein server macht es halt wenig sinn hoch verfügbares docker ja ich
glaube ich glaube dass das trifft eigentlich ganz gut sie sagen ja selbst sie sind ein
ein orchestrierungstool für container infrastruktur also du kannst damit deine container in deine
container verwalten du kannst damit zum beispiel einstellen dass du für einen ich nenne es mal
service auch wenn die kubernetes ein service was anderes ist das wird eine pence champ-reihe nur
wieso so schlimm so schlimm ist es auch das einzige problem an kubernetes ist so zumindest
wie ich das sehe also was vom lernen her dass es ein fass ohne boden ist es gibt 30 milliarden
tools fünf tools für die gleichen sachen jede woche spawnet irgendein neues tool die einfachsten
sachen werden teilweise super krass verkompliziert aber insgesamt ist es an sich an sich ist das doch
eine coole sache ja also was so interessiert also was so damit zum beispiel machen kann so
mal ganz simpler use case ja du hast drei server und möchtest also du willst du willst web service
anbieten willst web service anbieten und du willst dass das ganze möglichst verfügbar ist und du
willst dass das ding im laufenden betrieb geupdatet werden kann und du willst dass das auch je nachdem
wie viel user gerade drauf sind ordentlich performt oder eben auch skaliert wie man so schön nennt
dann ist kubernetes genau das richtige weil du kannst kubernetes nehmen stellst dir verschiedene
notes hin heißt das bei kubernetes also verschiedene server notes sind bei kubernetes in der regel die
unterschiedlichen server in dem cluster also cluster members sind quasi notes bei kubernetes das muss
ich zwangsläufig eine hardware kiste sein das können auch vor ems sein der neueste schrei ist
so was wie kubernetes auf firecracker vms wenn man das jetzt mal hört und jemand weiß nicht was
es ist er denkt jetzt erstmal was zum teufel will er von uns das machen wir heute nicht ich weiß nicht
ob wir es überhaupt im stream machen ist auch was ganz ganz ab abgedrehtes das sind minimal vms
firecracker das ist glaube ich von glaube das ist von amazon ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ich glaube
von amazon so eine minimal vm kubernetes selbst ist für container workload und der kubernetes
cluster besteht aus unterschiedlichen notes in der regel ist es halt ein server jeder note das
kann natürlich auch ein server sein worauf dann mehrere vms sind kann es kann es quasi auch sein
kubernetes cluster in mehreren vms die auf einem esk server laufen betreiben was auch immer oder
theoretisch kannst du das ding auch über mehrere cloud anbieter spannen wie dem auch sein da bist
sie sind ja deine kreativität keine grenzen gesetzt wieder das ganze aufbauen willst zumindest hast
du dann den vorteil dass du so schöne sachen machen kannst wie es gibt ein das machen wir
übrigens heute wenn wir so weit kommen du hast eine neue anwendungsversion und möchtest jetzt
wirst deine anwendung läuft zur zeit auf version 1 und du willst jetzt auf version 2 und dann kannst
du ein config file editieren du kannst darüber kommandos teile machen aber in der regel macht
man über config jammels dann drehst du ein ich will jetzt die version 2 von diesem moment
schicko ist an der tür schicko hat mich abgelenkt also wenn du keine ahnung davon hast und wenn
euer online shop so funktioniert dass nur ein service ist da brauchst wahrscheinlich kein kubernetes
cluster wie gesagt man muss es nicht man muss es auch nicht übertreiben manchmal tut es ohne
probleme 123 vms und reverse proxy für ssl davor also es muss nicht sein da ist schon da
ist schon ihr werdet wahrscheinlich so im lauf des streams ein bisschen an an klingen sehen da
ist schon auch wenn es erstmal easy aussieht eine gehörige portion komplexität drinne gar nicht
so sehr in den basis rein in basis funktion von kubernetes sondern das gesamte ökosystem drum
herum was es gibt ja wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben genau also du willst du hast ein
service laufen du willst den service jetzt abqueren wessen von version 1 auf version 2
normalerweise wird es dann auf dich und vm einloggen neu pullen vm den service wieder
starten was auch immer mit kubernetes geht es relativ einfach du gehst in den jammelfall machen
wir heute auch alles jammelfall trägst die neue container image version ein das image bauste
vorher irgendwo entweder lokal mit docker oder über jenkins oder github actions über irgendwelche
continues pipeline geschiss bauste dann image und pusht das in registry rein und dann trägst du
dann im jammelfall ein ich will jetzt auf version 2 dann applies du diese konfig machen wir jetzt
gleich alles dann applies diese konfig auf dein kubernetes cluster und es skaliert dann automatisch
rulli also der reihe nach deine einzelnen container hoch also nene nicht skaliert plötzlich der
reihe nach deine einzelnen container ja richtig stripes genau so dass der service nicht ausfällt
was ist der unterschied zwischen k8s und k3s ich glaube das eine ist irgendwie super
leichtgewichtiges kubernetes gibt es ein paar sachen es gibt ein paar sachen wenn man das
ist zum beispiel was was du eher auf dem raspberry pi laufen lassen kann kannst das ist aber glaube
ich soweit ich weiß 100 prozent api kompatibel zum großen kubernetes es gibt verschiedenste
sachen für minimal kubernetes es gibt es gibt das originale kubernetes oftmals mit k8s abgekürzt
gibt 3 ks gibt auch 0 ks es gibt kein es gibt mini cube es gibt alle möglichen dinger total
viel sachen mini schiff feiercube was auch immer alles wir nehmen heute mini cube wir nehmen heute
mini cube weil es am einfachsten ist für dich mit mini cube lokal ein bisschen rum zu basteln so
mini cube ist nahezu 100 prozent api kompatibel mit nahezu 100 prozent es kann halt einige sachen
nicht ich kann euch aber nicht aus dem kopf sagen was es aber zum größten teil api kompatibel mit
kubernetes und du kannst auch die ganz normalen kubernetes tools nehmen für für mini cube um
damit lokal was auszuprobieren ist halt ist halt hauptsächlich gedacht für auf einer kiste lernen
und üben mini cube wir machen jetzt mal ein eigenes wir machen jetzt mal ein eigenes verzeichnis
dafür repos mk dir nennen wir es einfach mal sogar du brauchst noch cube ctl ne brauche ich nicht
weil guck mal da ist es das ist mittlerweile bei mini cube dabei also was heißt dabei der
lädt es im hintergrund runter aber trotzdem ich installiere es trotzdem weil das braucht man
normalerweise hast du schon recht planer mission lernen ja also wie gesagt meine streams sind
ja immer so so ein ding also ich mache meistens sachen wo ich selbst ein bisschen schon von ahnung
habe aber nicht so krass den durchblick und dadurch dass ich das euch zeige und ein bisschen
was erklären muss lernt man selbst besser das ist immer ganz gute kombination so sieht es aus jetzt
können wir anfangen es ist relativ easy zu starten mit mini cube und zwar ihr braucht keine vm ihr
braucht kein kubernetes installation und nix ihr sagt einfach mini cube start und jetzt macht ihr
eine sache falls ihr das auch ausprobieren wollt ja macht ihr eine sache man muss mal kurz nachgucken
insecure oder mir ist das insecure registry macht jetzt mini cube start ins insecure registry werdet
gleich sehen warum so jetzt leider kopane das geht uns runter und direkt best practice ist lokal
es ist lokal übungs practice chat ihr werdet gedisst gerade im chat also quasi aber du bist
auch teil des chats kommt eigentlich ein video zu dem mobilfunk anbieter suchen was ich euch da
erzählen soll so ach ja es gibt verschiedene nummer so der vollständigkeit vollständigkeit
halber erwähnt es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten mini cube zu betreiben die standard variante ist
über irgendeinen virtualisierungs provider also meistens kvm also wenn ihr mini cube startet dann
legt es normalerweise unter der haupe neue vm an wenn man keine vm anlegen möchte kann man das
ganze auch selbst als container in docker laufen lassen ist ja kein ding ich mein kubernetes ist
ja letztendlich tool zur container verwaltung warum sollte man das nicht auch selbst in dem
container laufen lassen können also ihr seht ja hier ich habe keine vm install ich habe hier
keine virtualisierungsmöglichkeiten in der vm drinnen das heißt er lässt jetzt das back end
einfach in einem eigenen docker container laufen also es ist jetzt quasi kubernetes in docker
womit man eine weitere container verwalten gab es ist egal letztendlich muss man sich damit nicht
beschäftigen das ist ja zum üben und die api und wie man das anspricht und so ist überhaupt
kein unterschied also diese lokale lokales so entwicklungsumgebung mit mini cube können
die genauso benutzen wie also die du brauchst keine extra süntags ist quasi genau das gleiche wie
fürs große kuppernät ist nur dass es lokal bei einem auf dem rechner läuft sammar logial halb
ist irgendwie besoffen oder so ich kann dir nicht folgen was du für komisches teuch im chat schreibst
die ganze zeit was was soll was soll uns das sagen lokal geschützt von meter alles klar
written in rust container runtime nie kenne ich nicht ich kann ich jede rust software kennen ich
schreibe über mastadon schreibst du das einfach nur so oder oder schreibst du mit jemand ich
glaube ich glaube du machst aktuell die taktik was ich auch manchmal mache alles was einem in
den kopf fällt in irgendein text eingericht was einem in den kopf kommt in den text eingabe
fällt tippen und unterdrücken aber machen ruhig beschwer mich nicht alles interactions auf twitch
wobei das war youtube wo das so wichtig ist ach ja und wir brauchen tatsächlich anscheinend doch
kann nachher noch potman und so aber gucken wir uns an so also wir haben mini cube gestartet wir
können jetzt mal sowas machen wie cube ctl get ach nee ha sekunde leute lasst lasst euch nicht
jebaden von irgendwelchen youtube tutorials oder sowas ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie das die ganzen
youtube tutorial duz machen und dann zeige ich euch wie man es richtig macht ok also die ganzen
youtube nicht alle es gibt gut es gibt gute tutorials das beste deutschsprachige tutorial
auf youtube was ich kenne dazu kubernetes ist also für leute die ein bisschen ahnung von linux und
sich nicht vor kommando zeilen scheuen und relativ relativ ja schon ein bisschen bisschen background
was container angeht haben das ist das beste also wenn wenn sich einmal wirklich eine zwei
stunden in zwei stunden gut strukturiert das kubernetes tutorial angucken will finde ich das
persönlich auf deutsch finde ich das persönlich am besten ich könnte natürlich auch einfach
dabei bleiben weil ich wir werden ja wahrscheinlich nicht alles machen was er im video macht aber
ein großteil und ihr könnt ja live auch noch was dazu beitragen und wir machen auch ein paar
sachen die er so glaube ich nicht im video zeigt ich glaube es ist ein zertifikate über let's
encrypt macht er im video gar nicht aber wenn mal einer sich in ruhe einen tutorial angucken
will ich finde das hier ist das beste so genau also ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie das die ganzen
tutorial dudes auf youtube und auch teilweise auf judy und so machen wenn die kubernetes kommandos
oder generell wenn die kommando zeilen tools tools verwenden dann machen wir sowas hier guck
jub ctl get potts oder da machen sie so get events und solche dinger du siehst die typen
in tutorial videos zum kurz ich drücke schon in sie den ganzen krempel immer fünf mal tippen so
nicht so nicht leute das ist das ist mist auch wenn man das in allen möglichen tutorials sieht das
erste was man braucht ist und jeder linux admin wird wissen das erste was man braucht ist shell
completion leute jetzt nicht unbedingt für mini cube für mini cube ist das relativ egal dann
müssen wir nicht so viel machen aber für kubectl brauchen wir best completion gehört das ist
aktuell noch nicht der fall das geht noch nicht und wir wollen ja nicht nur einfach
tepp completion haben sondern wir wollen auch quasi ja kontextsensitive tepp completion haben
also wenn ich zum beispiel sage hier irgendwie describe potts oder potts genau describe nee
nee quatsch nee das kann ich so die ressource hinten dran schreiben blabla blub so und dann
will ich dass das auto completed so und dazu gibt es folgendes kubectl jetzt muss ich mal überlegen
wie das war completion zsh genau so kubectl bringt nämlich eine eigene completion definition
für best zsh und was noch best zsh wahrscheinlich mit richtig nice so und das kann man dann in
seine best zsh eintragen sieht dann folgendermaßen aus muss bloß mal kurz seine zhsh wie auch immer
shell konfig ich muss mal kurz gucken wo habe ich denn meine ach da da ist es doch muss doch
unten irgendwie sein source und wie machen das jetzt so geht das einfach so bin ich gerade
ein bisschen ich glaube ich glaube wir müssen es redirecten ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob
das so funktioniert nein aber ich habe ich habe dings da brauche ich nicht genau so ist gut ja
genau und jetzt habe ich kubectl und guck mal tapp tapp und jetzt habe ich autocomplete ja und
ihr seht autocomplete hier endpoints autocomplete und der autocomplete hat mir jetzt quasi auch
kontextsensitive infos so an der stelle gibt es halt einen endpoint der kubernetes heißt und
den kann ich da eintragen jetzt kann zum beispiel describe irgendwie sowas wie hier potts gibt
es halt pots gibt es halt noch kein man kann auch sagen all namespaces dann zeigt er dann
alle pots an die es gibt warum man get pots dann erzähle ich mal ein bisschen so was zur
zur benahmung wie kubernetes denkt dass man dinger nennen soll also das sind jetzt die laufenden
container die wir zur zeit haben in unserem kubernetes cluster wobei das nicht stimmt wobei
das nicht ganz richtig ist ich muss das ich muss das anders erklären also kubernetes ist zwar ein
orchestrierungstool für container aber kubernetes arbeitet gar nicht auf container basis das klingt
jetzt erstmal verwirrend aber wenn ich euch das ein bisschen genauer erklären wird hoffentlich
klarer und zwar das was somit kubernetes verwaltet sind zwar unter der haube container aber container
während in kubernetes zusammengefasst zu pots ein pot ist quasi so eine logische einheit wie
viel wir kam ein klasse du meinst wie viele notes mein klasse hat einen lokale vm gerade so also was
wollte ich jetzt sagen genau kubernetes das kleinste mit dem kubernetes hantiert sind pots pots ist so
die kleinste logische einheit die man die man mit kubernetes verwalten kann in der regel könnte
man sagen dass ein pot so was wie ein container ist wobei das nicht stimmt ein pot ist quasi
also ist quasi so der container für die container oder so dass so die so die der rahmen oder so die
kiste um die container klingt jetzt bescheuert kann man kann man echt schlecht beschreiben also
ich erkläre euch mal zum beispiel warum man das braucht ich erkläre ich mal warum man das braucht
und zwar mal angenommen du hast jetzt eine anwendung in die net anwendung ja die verpackst du in
container image und die lässt man als pot laufen dann ist der pot genau ein container drin aber du
könntest jetzt ja in diesem pot zum beispiel noch einen container für metriken haben oder noch
noch ein container für secrets oder noch ein container für reverse proxy oder so was also
könntest ja du könntest ja quasi damit die anwendung als einheit funktioniert also ein
docker compose file ist ein pot ja das kommt ungefähr hin wobei man sagen muss in so einem
docker compose file definierst du ja auch mehrere logische services die du miteinander verbindest
du kannst jetzt im docker compose file auch eine datenbank reinschreiben ein application server
und die dann miteinander verbinden das wird schon in einzelne pots machen also du würdest
quasi nur sachen die logisch zusammengehören in einen pot packen ja also zum beispiel ein container
für connection zu deinem secret store oder sowas in der richtung also werd mal angenommen deine
deine anwendung braucht api keys und sonstige geschichten die hast du nicht in einem kubernetes
cluster sondern irgendwo extern liegen und du willst es auch nicht in kubernetes cluster integrieren
dann kannst du dir noch einen zweiten container rein passen rein packen der nur dafür da ist
diese secrets zeig mal wie ist denn dieses bild ja ja genau also ja das ganze nennt sich
übrigens seit k wenn man noch mehrere container rein packt in so einen pot genau so was hier das
ist das ist ein schönes beispiel das ist das ist ein schönes schönes beispiel ja aber aber
chat gpt erklärt er nicht warum das ist ein schönes beispiel ja du hast zum beispiel deine
anwendung die schreibt logs und jetzt willst du diese log files allerdings zu irgendeinem
zentralen logserver schicken ja und die anwendung selbst kann kein syslog und hat auch kein bock
sich irgendwie mit log sam einsammeln dingern zu beschäftigen dann würdest du einen pot erstellen
der enthält die anwendung und noch einen zweiten container der dafür da ist die logs einzusammeln
und an irgendein zentrales log management system zu schicken das ist ein gutes beispiel ja du
könntest zum beispiel noch einen dritten container dabei machen der metriken bereit stellt für
prometheus monitoring oder sowas hast du quasi eine logische einheit also das hier wäre dann
quasi dein application server pot allerdings enthält er eben alle container in diesem pot die
die anwendung braucht um ebenso als logische einheit gestartet werden zu können und das zu
machen was sie machen soll eine datenbank wäre wiederum ein zweiter pot das ist eigentlich gar
nicht so verkehrt was was ein bisschen doof ist ein komponent ist die haben halt für alles
irgendwelche irgendwie was ist denn das das wurscht mir als wachung die halt für alles
irgendwelche bisschen bisschen ja gewöhnungsbedürftige bezeichnung ja container sind pots was schon
irgendwie klar ist weil ein pot mehrere container enthalten kann du hast deployments da versteht jeder
eigentlich was anderes darunter als irgendwelche komischen jammel files die pots definieren aber
gut da muss man sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnen was phippe goes to the zoo cloud native computing
foundation ist ein kubanete story moment jetzt lernen wir was ok pots hier hier werden pots
erklärt
ich verstehe den zusammenhang kann ich so genau
ich verstehe den zusammenhang zwischen diesem bild und und pots nicht wie dem auch sei wir
machen jetzt wir machen jetzt mal weiter man muss sich zumindest ein bisschen daran gewöhnen
dass die alles irgendwie irgendwie anders nennen und zwar ist es zum beispiel bei kubanete
ist auch so die nennen dort wo der traffic reingeht also quasi das was jeder normale
mensch irgendwie reverse proxy nennt das nennen die ingress zum beispiel und das gegenteil
von ingress also da wo der traffic quasi reingeht ist nicht etwa outgress sondern egress weil
ist halt so und da gibt wie gesagt gibt gibt gibt noch mehr sachen wo ganz komisch benannt
sind wo man sich einfach dran gewöhnen muss was genau ist mini cube mini cube ist ein tool
wo du lokal bei dir kubanete laufen lassen kannst zum üben also wir haben das ganze
noch nicht gestartet doch haben wir so also nach dem mini cube installiert ist es ganz
einfach über den package manager oder als single binary runterladen ist glaube ich auch
in go programmiert als single binary runterladen starten dann startet ihr mini cube am besten
dass ihr noch hinten dran wenn ihr lokale container registry haben wollt und gut ist
dann habt ihr mini cube gestartet euer kubanete läuft irgendwann mal läuft es dann und dann
könnt ihr auch schon kommandos an euren kubanete server schicken und das ganze machen mit kubectl
kubectl kubectl get pods zum beispiel so und man sieht ja schon folgendes das ist das wo
ich gerade am wo ich gerade am erzählen gewesen bin ein pot ist die kleinste logische einheit
die kubanete verwaltet kubanete selbst oder in dem fall mini cube selbst wenn du startest
kommt schon mit ein paar vor installierten pots um die musst du dich nicht kümmern das
siehst ja auch hier das ist im name space cube system und dort sind interne sind interne
pots die man die das braucht dass es funktioniert was zum beispiel hier sowas wie core dns das
ist das ist wichtig dafür dass die pots sich untereinander beziehungsweise auch die services
aufgelöst werden können und im cluster selbst die dienste per namen angesprochen werden
können und so was da muss man sich jetzt nicht so viel gedanken drüber machen aber damit
kommt das halt also sprich man sieht hier laufen schon ein paar container was man hier auch
schon sieht das brauchen wir später noch hier sieht man dass manche pots ready sind
es ist so in kubanetes dass ein also in docker ist es so du startest das ding so und entweder
es krascht oder es läuft aber zu wirklich großartig wissen wann das jetzt ready ist
und wann nicht tust du nicht ja du kannst den docker zwar einstellen dass er restarten
soll wenn es krascht aber wann die web anwendung darin gestartet ist und ich weiß nicht so
und nachdem es in kubanetes ja unter anderem darum geht dass das ganze möglichst ausfallfrei
läuft haben container oder pots muss man sagen sind da sind da keine container
haben container verschiedene möglichkeiten zu überprüfen ob sie bereit sind da gibt
es nämlich sowas was der andreas gerade schreibt es gibt sowas wie readiness und life nis da
kann man dann wirklich health checks auf die container machen auf die pots machen und erst
wenn die wirklich ready sind funktionieren also in dem fall dass ein web response web
request durchgeht bei einer anwendung erst dann kommen die quasi in den ready state und
der interne load balancer in kubanetes würde die dann ansteuern ja genau compose kann auch
sowas in der richtung ja ich finde hier ist das jetzt das schöner gemacht so also mit
was ich überlege gerade mit was wir anfangen wir machen uns erstmal eine leere datei nennen
wir das einfach mal hier touch keine ahnung cute punkt jammel und machen wir wishell studio
code auf wir trasten cute wir trasten nicht cute punkt jammel nope so jetzt können wir
als erstes mal die kubanetes extension installieren ja ja reload mal die kubanetes extension ist
nicht so dolle also ehrlich gesagt das einzige was ich von der kubanetes extension benutze
ist das hier jammel das jammel synthax autocomplete für kubanetes files so haben wir ihn gerade
installiert so das nächste ist ein config file für kubanetes also so ein jammel file
hier das nennt sich wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege manifest warum weil config datei zu
dumm ist weil die das immer gerne ein bisschen fancy nennen wenn was kubanetes angeht also
ein jammel konfig datei für kubanetes nennt sich manifest und in so einem manifest kann
man fast beliebig viele dinge reinschreiben die man konfigurieren will für sein kubanetes
cluster man kann mehr als eins reinschreiben allerdings muss man sich immer überlegen
man kann das waren wir jetzt auch gleich man kann diese datei immer nur im gesamten einlesen
lassen von kubanetes also wenn ich da jetzt 20 sachen drinne definiere und ich will dass
kubanetes den kram übernimmt dann immer nur alles auf einmal wenn alles in einer datei
entsteht also es macht durchaus sinn sachen die zusammengehören zusammen zu definieren
also man könnte jetzt zum beispiel wobei da schreiten sich ja die geister darüber was
man wie aufsplitten sollte in config files und ob man wie man es nennt und ob man für
jeden dings unterordner macht und dann ein eigenes jammel file für service deployment
was auch immer wir schreiben das jetzt erste mal sinnvoll zum zum üben schreiben wir das
jetzt erstmal alles in ein jammel file also wir brauchen erstmal eine testanwendung würde
ich sagen oder wir haben keine testanwendung wir machen man wir machen mal eine minimal
dotnet testanwendung wobei da müssen wir einen container bauen und sowas hello world
wir nehmen den hello world container da seht ihr auch schon mal gleich das wie das aussieht
wenn ein container crashed wir machen hello world hello world container der beendet sich
nämlich da werde ich gleich sehen als kubanetes aus 18 ding ist das ding läuft nicht mehr
also deployment so sieht ein kubanetes deployment aus ich mache mal kurz die schriftgrößen
ein ticken größer 18 wenn man sogar 20 kommen dass man gescheit was sieht wunderbar also
so sieht ein deployment in kubanetes aus das ist das das ist das template was hier diese
visual studio addon dabei hat also in deployment ist in kubanetes eine config die kubanetes
sagt welche container es starten soll ganz platt gesagt leute ich glaube euch im chat
dass ihr die super krassen kubanetes checker seid wahrscheinlich mehr als ich aber es
hat keinen sinn wenn wir jetzt alle 800.000 kubanetes tools die es gibt immer wild durcheinander
im chat schmeißen wie gesagt das ist ein unüberschaubare landscape an tools und sachen man könnte
es auch man könnte man könnte auch gar kein manifest schreiben und man kann das manifest
in python generieren das gibt es nämlich auch also wo wir gerade dabei sind man kann
auch so was verwenden guck wenn man keinen wenn man keinen bock auf jammel hat kann man
auch das komplett erstellen mit jeder x beliebigen programmiersprache was was haben die denn
ich glaube python java und noch was aber das ist einfach zu viel auf einmal
deswegen war jetzt erst mal jammel falls und gucken uns das ganze an so also was gibt
es denn so in einem deployment zu sehen erst mal in unseren namen ausdenken cute app super
toll ich mache noch mal deployment cute app dann haben wir hier so sachen wie meta data
das ist erst mal nicht so wild meta data kann man alles möglich reinschreiben es gibt übrigens
auch noch annotations schwachsinn was erzähle ich jetzt gibt labels es gibt labels und es
gibt annotations ich habe noch keine ahnung bzw ich habe ich habe noch nicht gecheckt
wozu man annotations überhaupt braucht ehrlich gesagt außer dass manche ja nennen wir es
mal third party tools gerne annotations benutzen normalerweise kommt man eigentlich mit labels
mehr oder weniger aus kannst du den programm kurz kurz erklären es gibt noch gar kein
programm code das ist das template was bristles studio macht wenn ich deployment wenn ich
deployment hinzufüge meiner kombiniertes konfig mehr gibt es da noch nicht also meta data name
das nennen wir mal cute app also quasi wie diese ressourcen ressourcen nennt sich das
übrigens was angelegt wird also diese ganze datei nennt sich manifest und was hier angelegt
wird ist glaube ich eine ressource und der typ der ressource ist in dem fall deployment
damit eure jammel files auch garantiert immer funktionieren gibt es hier oben eine api version
also das heißt mal angenommen die bringen version 2 irgendwann raus was viel viel mehr
sachen unterstützt und hier oben immer noch api version eins angegeben habt solange die
version eins weiter unterstützen funktioniert euer manifest auch weiter api version gibt
es übrigens für nahezu alle verschiedenen ressource typen so wir machen jetzt mal ein
bisschen zackig dann kannst du noch selektor und labels und so anlegen das ist wird gleich
das wird gleich relevanter wenn wir da noch ein load balancer und sowas und sowas da vorhängen
so template meta data labels können wir auch so lassen cute app manifest v2 und v3 kann
das war das in chrome ja sondern hier schreiben wir unser docker image rein beziehungsweise
unser container image also nehmen wir einfach mal hello world das so diese hello docker container
dann kann man noch limits eintragen wie viel ram und cpu das verwenden darf ich kann euch
ehrlich gesagt nicht genau sagen in welcher einheit die cpu ist das ist irgend sowas irgendwas
super super spezielles das ist nicht einfach nur anteile von einem cpu kern das sind irgendwelche
megahertz nicht höchstwahrscheinlich nicht irgendwie irgendwie cpu zeit oder sowas was
auch immer das habe ich nicht so genau gecheckt was das jetzt für eine einheit ist zumindest
ram ist relativ klar und man sollte auch limits angeben das ist sinnvoll weil wenn ihr mal
eine anwendung habt mit memory leak dann frisst ihr euch im zweifelsfall euren kompletten
note an ram voll wenn ihr da keine limits angegeben habt das heißt man sollte immer
man kann durchaus großzügige limits angeben muss ja gar nicht sein aber ganz ohne limits
ist meistens doof weil man kann kubernetes auch so einstellen beziehungsweise macht
automatisch mal angenommen ihr habt memory leak und die anwendung wird immer größer
immer größer immer größer und irgendwann nach einem gigabyte ram gerät es ans limit
und kackt ab dann startet kubernetes die neu und dann läuft das ding wieder eine woche
oder so was auch immer bis es wieder abkackt wegen memory leaks aber ganz ohne limits ist
doof so container port tja geben wir einfach mal container port 80 ein wir haben kein container
port weil dieses image kein port aufmacht sollen jetzt sagen wir mal kubectl deploy
apply nicht deploy apply minus f cute wir machen hier unten mal was auf watch kubectl
get pots ihr seht es gibt noch keine pots aber jetzt gibt es einen pot gibt es nämlich
ein cute app pot und ihr seht das ding ist gleich wieder abgekackt weil es ist kein pot
der also das ist der standard docker hello world pot den ich hier gestartet habe der
macht nichts anderes wie hello world ausgeben kuck docker run hello world der macht nichts
anderes wie hello world ausgeben sich wieder zu beenden deswegen da hier guck hier deswegen
funktioniert das natürlich nicht kubanete sieht aha anwendung startet anwendung krascht
kubanetes denkt die anwendung krascht weil die läuft ja nicht mehr und jetzt jetzt versucht
er die neu zu starten und das krascht immer wieder doch doch der hat gepullt das geht
das geht nur relativ relativ zackig das ist ja auch nichts nix dabei sind das docker image
wofür muss man docker auch installiert sein nein du brauchst docker nicht installiert
haben ich habe einfach bei mir lokal docker installiert und das sind streng genommen sind
docker images ja aber streng genommen sind docker images ja gar keine docker images mehr
sondern sind oci images oder wie dieser kram jetzt heißt open container images also das
ist was heißt ein oci open container image open container initiative image alles klar
wäre auch zu einfach gewesen also das ist eine spezifikation von container images die
auch docker verwendet aber mittlerweile auch ganz viele andere container tools aus dem
container ökosystem also es muss kein docker image in dem sinn sein aber bietet sich jetzt
in dem fall an so jetzt haben wir ein hello world container der niemals ready wird weil
er immer krascht wie gesagt logisch weil naja macht ja macht ja auch nichts der beendet
sich ja auch einfach wieder so bevor wir ein netzwerk container starten können wir ja machen
who am i traffic container traffic who am i kommen wir mal starten wir bauen gleich
noch eine kleine eigene dot net anwendung das dauert zwei minuten so jetzt sehen wir
mal hier das zum beispiel traffic who am i das ist was mit einem webserver wir applyen
die datei wieder ihr erkennt ein gewisses muster wenn ihr schon mal beispielsweise euch
den terraform stream angeguckt habt von mir das war ja oder generell wenn die terraform
oder solche infrastructure management tools verwendet habt ihr erkennt ein gewisses muster
es gibt eine config datei dessen state dann applied wird wobei man sagen muss terraform
ist da etwas advanced als die reinen kopernetes manifest weil da werden teilweise nicht die
states getrackt also wenn ich das hier jetzt um benenne dann kann es durchaus sein dass
der pot weiter läuft so mal gucken zumindest jetzt starten wir mal anderen container so
und wir sehen schon der alte container wurde gestartet und dann der neue container wurde
gestartet der alte container wurde gestoppt ich nenne mal container es ist eigentlich
ein pot ja steht man auch hier oben aber irgendwie kommt mir container einfacher von den lippen
wurde gestartet und der scheint jetzt auch zu funktionieren der ist running der ist ab
der ist abend running und das passt ja eigentlich soweit ganz gut jetzt muss man sich natürlich
überlegen ok ich bin übrigens gar nicht sicher ob das ding standardmäßig auf pot 80 läuft
das ist eine gute frage doch kann man probieren aus weiß ich gar nicht was macht das standardmäßig
pot 80 ok alles klar dann ups na geil jetzt eine sache wo ich nicht weiß wie das in meinem
neuen terminal geht wie switche ich die terminals jetzt lull einfach gar nicht aber irgendwie
geht das ich war noch nie in der ich musste das noch nie ausprobieren so jetzt ist natürlich
die sache gut wir haben jetzt wir haben jetzt ein pot laufen mit einem service drinnen
auf pot 80 wir kommen da allerdings nicht dran also selbst wenn ich mal karl lokal host oder
so da geht nix ich kann mir mal zum beispiel die mini cube ip angucken und dann kann ich
sagen karl ip auf mini cube geht aber auch nicht also der läuft zwar und dann wir wissen
auch dass da was auf pot das wird funktionieren ja wir können wir können auch mini cube tunnel
und so gedürnt machen kann man alles machen aber man sieht der container ist nicht so
wirklich erreichbar damit ein container erreichbar ist müssen wir erst einen service davor bauen
einen service kann man sich so als art ja ne kann man nicht wirklich laut balancer kann
man nicht so als eingang kann man sich so als eingang zu diesem zu diesem zu diesen pots
vorstellen so und jetzt kommt das was ich am anfang gesagt habe man kann in so einen
kubernetes manifest nahezu beliebig viele ressourcen definieren und wir machen es jetzt
zu übungszwecken so dass wir den service für dieses deployment also im prinzip für die
anwendung hier unten drunter definieren ich finde das ich finde das an der stelle nicht
verkehrt das gehört hier auch direkt zusammen das kann man kann man finde ich schon machen
an der stelle da streiten sich tatsächlich da jetzt die geister dran wie man das macht
und auch wie man das benennt ja ich kenne leute machen ordner also gut ordner ist prinzipiell
für einzelne anwendung nicht verkehrt machen ordner machen darunter dann immer so was
wie deployment extra service sonst wie manche machen auch eine datei mit dem namen von dem
jeweiligen jeweilige anwendung dieser trennen laufen lassen wollen und schreiben dann deployments
und service in eine datei allerdings ingress in der ande ist ein bisschen ist die musik zu
laut wirklich passt doch eigentlich oder bin ich zu leise ich glaube die ist an sich einfach nur
gerade ein bisschen sehr intensiv ok komm wir machen dass alle happy sind so jetzt ist
minimal leiser aber immer noch gut
so also damit diese pots verfügbar sind oder wahrscheinlich müsste man eher sagen dass die
pots aus diesem deployment verfügbar sind also nicht nur innerhalb des clusters sondern auch
von außen muss man da ein service da vorne service ist quasi so der eingang zu einem deployment
denkt das kann man ganz gut sagen es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten wie man services
definieren kann also verschiedene typen von von services der in dem fall jetzt ganz praktische
service wäre so was wie den load balancer zum beispiel weil wir machen auch gleich noch
mehrere mehrere pots hier aktuell ist es ja nur ein potter läuft so also sagen wir jetzt hier mal
service jetzt muss ich mal kurz überlegen meter meter meter data kann das gleiche sein das ist
übrigens auch da streiten sich auch die geister dran ob das hier nicht irgendwie app heißen soll
und das irgendwie service da kann man sich da kann man sich auch darüber streiten wie man das machen
will so port port muss rein wo ich möchte dass dieser service erreichbar ist von außen in dem
fall sagen wir auch mal pot 80 und taget port ist auch 80 kann man im kubernetes manifest auch
immer schießen ja ja klar warum nicht das ja ganz normal textart ganz normales jammel so das heißt wir legen jetzt ein service an auf port 80 der
auf diesen service ich nenne es mal balanced balanced an der stelle oder nicht so und hier
ist das entscheidende hier im selektor entscheidet man jetzt wohin dieser service seine requests
weiterleitet also nur weil das in der gleichen ratei drinne steht bedeutet das nicht automatisch
dass das zusammen gehört also hier wo ich den selektor angebe selektor ab cute ab und ihr
seht hier das hier ist ich vermute mal dass hier ist das relevante zumindest hier drauf
match der also der guckt danach was es für deployments gibt was es für pots gibt mit
diesem passenden tag dazu und dann balanced er da drauf also sprich ist es egal in welchen
dateien die stehen ja das da so also wir sagen wir wollen alle so und jetzt damit das ganze
hier testweise funktioniert müssen wir noch ein typ angeben man sieht es gibt mehrere typ
es gibt cluster ip ich glaube cluster ip ist der default wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege
excellent load balancer node port so mal gucken ob ich das aus dem kopf halbwegs hinkriege
also external name weiß ich jetzt gar nicht was heißt cluster ip hat heißt dieser service
kriegt eine ip aus dem cluster zugewiesen also irgendeine ip aus der aus der cluster range
node port bedeutet auf dem jeweiligen cluster knoten wo der container gerade läuft kriegt
er kriegt er was zugewiesen und also ne random port zwischen 30.000 und 35.000 oder so und
in dem fall will ich load balancer haben und jetzt applyn wir das ganze mal und dann hoffe
ich dass ich nichts vergessen habe und der kram funktioniert jetzt können wir zum beispiel
hier unten mal sagen kubectl get service und man sieht da aha gucke mal da wir haben ein
load balancer angelegt mit dieser cluster ip per external ip pending kann ruhig pendeln
so viel will und ein port mapping das heißt wenn ich jetzt einen curl mache mini cube ip
können wir uns merken wenn ich jetzt einen curl drauf mache da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich
gedacht dass es funktioniert
mit mini cube ich habe das selbst so mit mini cube schon gemacht da hat ja auch eine klasse
ne ne die klasse die klasse ip da müsstest du dich tunnen ne ne ne ne ne das funktioniert
so glaube ich oder das ist immer jetzt jetzt jetzt lernen wir was ok wir probieren mal
was aus braucht der lb nicht noch eine externe ip ne der hat einen port mapping das sollte
eigentlich ich meine wir könnten jetzt weiter gehen und noch noch den inquest davor machen
aber sollte das nicht einfach so gehen jetzt ok ok also übrigens ich sage mal das hier
funktioniert an der stelle nicht ja die du kannst die dinger nicht erreichen du kannst
aber zum beispiel sagen mini cube ssh und dann müsste es da drinne war scheine da gehts
auch nicht ne ne ne ich brauch kein ingress wenn ich das hier ok mal gucken wie das mit
cluster ip ist ich hätte jetzt eigentlich wecken können das funktioniert so egal probieren
mal aus apply ja guck mal mal hier unten was er macht cluster ip das das wird das wird
so natürlich auch nicht funktionieren ich bin mir das muss das muss mit load balancer
doch funktionieren ja node port können wir auch ausprobieren das in dem fall ja immer
immer das gleiche in dem fall macht es ja keinen unterschied ist ja immer der gleiche
node irgendwas habe ich irgendwas habe ich verkehrt gemacht irgendwas ergibt gerade keinen
weiter machen und den und den reverse proxy davor pappen ach ich weiß was ich mache was
ich falsch mache ich benutze es doch auch falsch ich benutze es falsch leute ich habe
alles richtig gemacht ich habe alles richtig gemacht ich bin bescheuert also apply ist
es stimmt alles passt mal auf es stimmt alles ich hab das nur falsch gemacht so natürlich
die cluster ip ist ja nicht erreichbar intern deswegen muss ich jetzt folgendes machen mini
cube cube service cute app aha und siehe da das service funktioniert da hätte ich
draufgemusst ich hätte ja auf die gemäbte auf den gemäbten port gehen müssen guck
auf den port hätte ich gehen müssen der map der port 30.000 430 466 auf port 80 von dem
von dem container so so ist richtig jetzt funktioniert so das ist das ist mein service
der hier läuft das ist dieser hallo welt container von von traffic das ist der mini cube ip mit
dem porter weitergeleitet wird ne ne load balance hast recht wahrscheinlich bräuchte
ich das bräuchte ich das nicht wir können es mal wir können es mal weglassen und gucken
ob es dann funktioniert nope siehst du funktioniert nicht notport würde funktionieren notport
würde in dem fall wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren hallo mein gott ist das auto komplett wieder
buggy ups ja das funktioniert auch also laut balancer braucht man an der stelle nicht wirklich
das service type notport auch externer ja das müssen wir gesagt ich will es ja da gar
nicht übertreiben so zumindest man sieht das service funktioniert damit was man jetzt ja
schon sieht was ein bisschen doof ist ich meine wer kann hier wer hantiert da mit den dinger
wer kann er mit rum hantieren mit den ports und und so also ich meine woher will jetzt
zum beispiel jemand der auf mein service zugreift woher will der wissen dass er das über port
32 259 machen muss das kann er nicht wissen so was man jetzt machen könnte ist man stellt
das hier auf typ load balancer und mit einer wirklich extern erreichbaren ip dann müsstest
du aber die jedes mal wenn du das über den cloud anbieter machst da müsste es müsste
sich quasi über jedes mal müsstest du dann eine externe ip ressource anlegen in deiner
cloud und hast dann am ende ganz viele externe ip viel sinnvoller ist es an der stelle sowas
wie ein reverse proxy davor zu pappen was wir auch schon gemacht haben mit docker compose
mit docker mit zeug haben wir im stream schon öfters gemacht und zwar ein reverse proxy
der dann auch am besten mit einem gültigen let's encrypt zertifikat ausgestattet ist
und der über port 80 und 443 erreichbar ist das heißt neben dieser definition von den
pots und dem service brauchen wir jetzt noch was für eingehenden traffic und das nennt
sich bei kubernetes ingress das gegenteil von ingress ist egress nicht outgress so da
gibt es verschiedene programme die man verwenden kann man kann traffic verwenden man kann
engine x verwenden oder ha proxy oder sowas wir verwenden jetzt bei engine x aus dem einzigen
grund weil bei minikube schon in engine x addon für ingress dabei ist und das macht
man folgendermaßen also wenn ihr eine richtig fette kubernetes installation habt die bei
einem klauenanbieter läuft oder könnte natürlich daneben was ihr wollt aber minikube bringt
verschiedene addons mit und da ist zum beispiel dabei sowas wie ein ingress und das ist in
dem fall engine x das hat noch mehrere praktische addons dabei zum beispiel registry die benutzen
wir auch gleich noch wir machen nämlich eine eigene dotnet anwendung die wir dann deployen
hier über zu der lokalen zu der lokalen lokale container registry ich muss mal kurz überlegen
in welcher reihenfolge wir das machen also ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt als erstes
mal wir machen das in zwei stufen wir machen als erstes den ingress dann machen wir die
dotnet an das drei zeilen dotnet das dauert nicht lang die dotnet anwendung und eine lokale
registry und dann machen wir gültige let's encrypt zertifikate für den ingress ich glaube
das ist eine gute reihenfolge das so zu machen ok das heißt als erstes enable wir mal unseren
engine x addons enable ingress so und jetzt muss das muss ich ein bisschen abgucken leute
das kriege ich nämlich aus dem kopf nicht gebacken so also wir haben unsere pots bei
der gelegenheit ihr seht hier vielleicht kommt mal mal watch ihr seht hier wir haben aktuell
nur einen pot laufen also quasi einen pot mit einem container drin das ist natürlich
jetzt nicht sonderlich ausfallsicher man kann sagen das ist natürlich eh nicht ausfallsicher
weil das alles auf meiner vm läuft aber geben wir mal von aus es wäre nicht so ich habe
im anfang gesagt eigentliches kombiniert ist dafür da um mehrere instanzen so von containern
für uns zu verwalten deswegen kann man auch sagen man möchte mehrere davon laufen haben
da geht man hier hinten den moment wo muss man da hin templates ach fuck ich kann mir
das immer nicht merken in spex spex muss man das irgendwo ist ein replica reinschreiben
man alter wo muss denn das wo muss denn das hin muss doch unter spex oder ist das nicht
nur das muss doch unter spex bin im deployment oder nicht ach da in die spex meine güte ja
ich bin großer jammel fan was das angeht also da kann man jetzt eingeben wie viele pots
standardmäßig laufen sollen sagen wir mal zum beispiel fünf ja komm vier wenn ich das
jetzt noch mal apply werdet ihr feststellen auf einmal hoch guck mal da wir haben jetzt
vier container das heißt unsere anwendung läuft jetzt vier mal und wenn ich jetzt hier
service aufmach und funktioniert das auch kein ding aber es gibt noch mehr möglichkeiten
der chrome kecht ja scheint so wir können das ganze auch noch mal stimmt aber machen
wir das ganz mal mit karl guckt ihr seht jetzt auch die ip ändert sich immer seht
ihr das guck 12 6 12 10 11 also ihr seht die ip ändert sich immer ich komme immer
auf unterschiedlichen pots raus guck mal 69 pots machen wir jetzt mal jetzt wird hyper
scaled hier apply ich hoffe das geht überhaupt meiner vor allem gescheit bämm jetzt haben
wir die anwendung 69 mal laufen wenn ich jetzt in köln mache müssen wir kurz warten bis
alles erstellt wurde das ist leute ist das high performer mindset
jetzt habe ich so und guckt ich lande jetzt jedes mal auf einem anderen oder fast jedes
mal auf dem anderen pot ihr seht sie an der ip oben so und jetzt guck mal was wo man jetzt
schon mal sieht dass es sehr praktisch ist so ein container orchestrierungstool zu verwenden
es gibt natürlich auch möglichkeiten das automatisch zu skalieren anhand der last der
ram auslastung und sonst was das machen wir heute nicht das nächste mal geben wir mal
was realistisches runter ich sag jetzt mal vier jetzt sage ich apply und passt auf es
wird automatisch runter skaliert auf nur vier laufende pots warum ich linux verwende weil
man gerade so netzwerk und technische sachen viel besser unter linux machen kann minikube
unter windows geht auch dann macht ja unter der haube glaube ich eine hyper vvm in der
dann aber höchstwahrscheinlich linux läuft weil letztendlich sind es ja alles linux container
und ich finde so sachen unter linux zu machen tausendmal angenehmer als unter windows allein
schon dass man ein gescheites terminal hat ja das neue terminal unter windows ist halbwegs
erträglich aber nix ging ordentlich ordentliche linux umgebung so jetzt habt ihr gesehen man
kann den kram hier auch ordentlich rauf und runter und runter skalieren wie man will am
besten ist natürlich später man macht das automatisch aber das gucken wir uns bei einem
anderen stream an da habe ich auch gerade gesagt vor zwei minuten so soll das mal überlegen was
wollte ich als nächstes machen genau also wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt den ingress
controller also es ist immer noch das problem dass ich ihren karl machen muss mit so einem
komischen port normalerweise will man ja dass jemand so drauf zugreifen am besten noch mit
einem dns namen ja darauf zugreifen kann also gar nicht gar nicht mal mit einem dns vor allem
aber auf jeden fall über port 80 und dann auf dem richtigen service rauskommt das heißt wir
brauchen jetzt noch irgendein service der das ob dessen ingress ingress template hat ja wir
brauchen das noch irgendein service der eben am eingang sitzt das entgegen nimmt und dann
weiter leitet an den service wiederum an die pots so das ganze nennt sich mal kubanet das
nennt sich das ingress also nennen wir das hier mal cute app ingress weiß ja nicht ob
es minus in ingress wir können es wenn jetzt aber wieder cute aber es könnte ja mehrere
eingänge geben aber machen sie jetzt einfach mal so so host
da können wir jetzt in dns name eintragen was auch sinnvoll ist ja dann nehmen wir jetzt
nehmen wir jetzt zum beispiel mal kackel punkt keck w punkt services prefix alles service
bei service kommt jetzt der name rein das service ist was wir hier oben definiert haben das ist cute
und bei port port 80 so und da muss man jetzt und da muss man jetzt ein bisschen gucken hier
geht es drum um also um den target service nicht nicht hier irgendwie vom vom ingress controller
dann brauchen wir noch ein paar andere sachen damit das ganze funktioniert das ist so magic
kubaniertes zeug und das muss ich jetzt abgucken weil das kriege ich aus dem kopf nicht hin wir
verwenden als eingangs proxy engine x das heißt ich muss das wie gesagt das gucke ich ab das war
ich aus dem kopf nicht ingress classname muss ich eintragen nämlich engine x warum weil es
sonst nicht funktioniert ja ja mit brauchste brauchste ultra white screen monitoren so und
wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht habe was ich mal hoffe dann sollten wir jetzt den ingress
bekommen der sich für diese domain zuständig fühlt und dahin weiter leitet apply ok cube ctl
get ingress what the fuck ingress ja haben wir host kekel punkt keck we services port 80 damit
das damit das ganze funktioniert lokal müssen wir folgendes machen und zwar in die host datei
dieses ding hier mal eintragen also keck we punkt services aus dem kopf ip ist zuerst ja ip ist
zuerst genau ip ist zuerst weil einer ip mit mehreren amt und 49 punkt 2 ist glaube ich die
mini cube ip ok guck mal mal pink pink ok karl moment der wahrheit es funktioniert chrome was
nein chrome und siehe da keckel keck we punkt services ist verfügbar unter der domain und
wir kommen auf unseren verschiedenen verschiedenen pots raus also der der traffic fluss ist jetzt so
ich muss den namen auflösen in dem fall hier keckel punkt keck we punkt services da kommt die
ip von meinem kubanet ist klasse da raus 192 168 49 punkt 2 dann geht das hier in den engine
x ingress controller rein der leitet es weiter auf dieses backer der leitet wohlgemerkt alles
weiter man kann auch sagen ich möchte bloß ab hier weiter leiten und so was er leitet alles weiter
an dieses backer mit dem namen cute app auf port 80 also auf den service cute port 80 den service
haben wir hier definiert taget port port das ist das worauf der ingress controller das ganze
weiter leitet und der service selbst verteilt das dann wieder auf alle möglichen pots so heißt im
endeffekt es funktioniert auch immer noch wenn ich hier reinschreibe 69 pots machen wir es
noch mal apply damit skaliert das ganze hoch diagonales fife hat hyperskalierungs cloud native
zeug wird hoch skaliert und wenn ich jetzt wieder ein köln mache auf keck we punkt services sehen
wir kriegen fast immer eine andere ip und wir landen jetzt auf einem von 96 69 verschiedenen
pots kann euch das sogar zeigen dass das relativ viel viel ab kann was jetzt kein wunder ist wir
können mal einen htp benchmark starten können man htp benchmark starten sowas wie hey für eine
minute warum geht altpunkt nicht was sind das z mal zehn sekunden zehn sekunden volle pulle
und ihr seht guck mal meine cpu last hier oben ist jetzt einfach mal ist jetzt einfach mal 100
prozent oh ja habe ich hatte tp vergessen ihr seht auch meine laut geht übelst hoch ja und
wir haben 195.000 request geschickt alle hatten hat tp status 200 hat wohl funktioniert ich bin
mir jetzt gerade aus dem kopf nicht sicher wie man sich kommando zeilen mäßig die auslastung
anzeigen lassen kann gibt es kubectl top oder so dinge also man kann zusatztools sowas wie
lens und sowas verwendet aber mal gucken ob kann man kubectl top gibt sowas pot node node
minicube matrix api not verfügbar ok minicube addons enable matrix server ist das so ok ok
wo ich das restarten oder so das könnte jetzt eine minicube geschichte sein dass das nicht will
matrix server ist enabled der ram ist voll quatsch glaube ich nicht achso ja doch das
könnte tatsächlich sein ich war mal kurz vier aber ich glaube nicht dass da voll ist weil so
dieser container braucht ja nichts ich glaube da hat keine schmerzen so wir sehen hier ist
autocomplete das ok naja ich meine wir können einfach mal minicube können das ding mal neu starten moment moment in secure und
registries ich glaube dann einfach probleme mit der matrix api wir starten wir starten das ding mal
neu vielleicht geht es dann muss man manchmal machen ich hatte schon öfters das minicube lokal
manche sachen nicht wollte da muss man das neu starten oder funktioniert das wird jetzt mal
neu starten dann gucken so weil als nächstes gucken wir uns mal an wie man das mit lokaler
image registry macht weil aktuell verwenden wir hier öffentliche public verfügbare docker
images das ist ja meistens nicht der fall also wenn man eigene anwendung laufen lassen will da
will man in der regel nicht diese anwendung public in einem docker container beziehungsweise
ein container image ins internet stellen zumindest viele wollen das nicht jetzt geht's
ok minicube hat keinen bock
minicube not found ok
kann ich sowas machen wie get node also minicube wie dem auch sei pot ich kann eine pot ressource
mir anzeigen lassen kann man das so watchen lassen oder muss man das von hand machen wir
führen jetzt noch mal den kram hier aus also moment die selbst können ja gar nicht so viel
sachen hier abkommen dass ich das sehe bin ich ein bisschen doof dass es nicht geht aber
ach jetzt funktioniert not minicube auf einmal ok alles klar nice gut zu wissen hat man sich
einfach ein bisschen gedauert bis es gestartet ist und sagt jetzt würde ich eigentlich erwarten
dass der ein bisschen mehr ausgelastet ist ist er nicht hatte aber kein bock drauf denkt sich
nope was was interessieren mich 128.000 naja gut machen wir mal machen wir einfach mal mehr
potz misst ja apply
ja wieder jede menge potz am start das ding ist hat einfach nur eine krasse krasse verzirkt
ne wobei das ist jetzt jetzt pot erstellen so und jetzt mal nochmal arttp benchmark mein
ganzer rechner ist voll man es könnte auch sein dass das irgendwie richtig funktioniert
weil das im container läuft keine ahnung ich weiß eh nicht wie man sich das gescheit auf
kommando zeile anzeigen lässt anscheinend so aber wirklich funktionieren tut es tut es ja
nicht wirklich ja cpu 15 prozent na gut durchaus möglich dass es nicht mehr sein kann als 15
prozent weil ich ja nur in zwei kerne docker container hab für mein minicube ach guck jetzt
geht es ein bisschen hoch also wirklich wirklich wirklich toll zur übersicht ist das ist das nicht
gut aber jetzt war mal wieder was gescheites jetzt machen wir eine lokale container registry
normalerweise ist es ja so wenn ihr anwendungen programmiert habt oder wenn ihr in einem
unternehmen seid das der anwendung entwickelt hat und das auf kubernetes deployed werden soll
dann ist das ja keine open source anwendung die irgendwo im internet verfügbar ist ja das
kenne ich das kenne ich habe ich aber noch nicht benutzt ich kenne das ich habe ich habe erst
gestern mir paar kubernetes frontends angeguckt so und dementsprechend willst du ja auch keine
container images bauen mit deiner close source super secret versicherungsbanken anwendung und
hier auf docker hab öffentlich ins internet pushen so was du natürlich machen kannst ist wenn die
firma in der cloud ist und in einem cloud anbieter vertraut kann man eine container registry verwenden
also ich sag mal ihr kennt docker hab wahrscheinlich docker hab ist so die älteste container registry
die es gibt docker hab ist nicht die einzige github hat beispielsweise auch eine eigene
container registry docker hab kennen die meisten aber so docker hab ist halt public oder man meldet
sich an und kriegt da auch ein private account aber es ist immer noch in der cloud das ist im
internet also vielleicht möchte man nicht seine anwendung oder die das unternehmen die anwendung
ins internet stellen entweder benutzt man an irgendeine registry wie docker hab allerdings
bloß angemeldet und private oder github private registry oder man hostet sich eine container
registry selber ich persönlich würde eher dazu tendieren die container registry nicht selber
zu hosten sondern die von jeweiligen cloud anbieter zu nehmen also wenn man zum beispiel bei amazon
ist bei asia oder bei google oder geben wir mal bei google wenn ihr wenn ihr gcp google cloud kunde
seid da könnt ihr auch da eine container registry verwenden für unseren fall werden wir jetzt eine
lokale container registry mit mit einem add-on was im minikube eingebaut ist verwenden das ist ganz
praktisch dann muss ich mich hier nirgendswo anmelden docker hab technisch sondern kann das hier alles
lokal machen dann machen wir eine kleine dotnet anwendung und die packen wir dann anstelle hier
von who am i traffic container packen wir in einen docker container bzw. bauen container image und
pushen das zu unserer lokalen container registry und bei der gelegenheit gucken wir uns dann auch
noch ein paar einheiten an damit man so was updaten kann ohne dass die anwendung dabei ausfällt so wir
machen jetzt erstmal hier in den ordner nennen wir mal app so dotnet habe ich überhaupt habe ich
überhaupt sp dotnet runtime installiert sp habe ich gar nicht nur dachte mir doch irgendwie ich
gehe mal kurz durch den chat durch was was da so gekommen ist ich habe wieder die hälfte nicht
gelesen wenn firmenleute mit kubernetes erfahrung suchen wo ist dann in dem job genau die
schwierigkeit dass die firmen wahrscheinlich gar nicht wissen was sie wollen ich glaube viele
denken sie wollen kubernetes weil man das kennt und damit ja automatisch alles agil wird uns
skaliert automatisch und alles super verfügbar ist das ist aber ein trugschluss also man ist
wahrscheinlich mit bekannter technologie mit leuten die sich damit auskennen besser als wenn
man jetzt übers kniepricht kubernetes für irgendeinen anwendungszweck wo es vielleicht
noch gar nicht mal großartig sinnvoll ist ja sie so dankeschön für den sub also ich glaube die
größte schwierigkeit ist dass die firmen wahrscheinlich nicht so genau wissen was sie
wollen und ansonsten das für mich komplizierteste was kubernetes angeht ist eindeutig in dem
ökosystem den überblick zu behalten wie gesagt ich habe es am anfang gesagt ich bin auch nicht
die pot sind running ich bin auch nicht das super krasse kubernetes checker ja und das
ökosystem ist wirklich unglaublich komplex es gibt für es gibt für alles acht verschiedene
lösungen allein schon allein schon wie speichert man api keys und passwörter in kubernetes da
gibt es fünf sechs verschiedene varianten von einfach bis super von ein bisschen einfacher
und super kompliziert nee habe ich nicht
als secrets storst du die besser nicht weil als secrets steht das im klaren text in
dein jammel files drinnen das kann man machen aber sobald ein jammelfile ins git einchecks
stehen deine secrets im klaren text drinnen so da gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten es gibt so
sachen wie ziel secrets dann speichert man das ganze verschlüsselt verschlüsselt im git und
entsperrt das quasi per key beim kubernetes cluster start dann gibt es irgendwas komisches
von mozilla was quasi irgendwie so ein makro für jammel files ist dann gibt es so was wie
wollt und so da wird es aber schon langsam richtig kompliziert also gibt es unglaublich viel geschiss
drumherum also gibt es ganz viel also da die ich glaube es gibt keinen den überblick behält
ja da gibt es so sachen wie helm wo dran steht es ist ein paket ein package manager für kubernetes
und du guckst dir mal helm chart definitionen an und musst erst mal kotzen wenn du die dateien
siehst also da gibt es dann ja auch es ist auch nicht das einzige was es gibt gibt es auch wieder
drei verschiedene sachen dann kannst du im zweifelsfall auch einfach sagen ach ich scheiß auf
jammel und kannst es direkt über terraform machen terraform hat auch kubernetes provider
und das ist also dadurch zu blicken ist tatsächlich für mich für mich das schwierigste
ich blicke da auch nicht durch soll ich ganz ehrlich also es gibt es gibt so viele sachen wo
ich keine ahnung von hab an sich tools was es für möglichkeiten gibt und und später wenn es dann
richtung service mesh und solche geschichten geht habe ich mich auch nur am rande mit beschäftigt
da wird sein ganz abgedreht also muss sagen so die basic funktion von kubernetes sowas wie das was
wir gemacht haben das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so schwer wenn man sich ein bisschen an die namen
gewöhnt hat wie die den kram nennen aber das was damit dann noch zusätzlich kommt macht es
kompliziert eine sache werden wir vielleicht gleich noch sehen mit manager und und zertifikate
anlegen damit es dann schon wieder ein bisschen komplizierter so aber wir bauen jetzt mal eine
eigene dotnet anwendung die wir benutzen als application als application wie gesagt leute
kein dotnet programmier stream das wird was ganz kleines was im prinzip nur aus drei zeilen
oder so besteht so also dort net new web neue dotnet anwendung und verwendest du das wim plug-in
wischl zu kontinue wenn ich wim aufmache ist es der real wim noch nicht mal neowimp der
schlüssel tatsächlich da stinkt normale wim das ok ja ich traste traste alles hier voller
trust dotnet anwendung am start ja das habe ich da habe ich da habe ich jetzt gar nicht
dran gedacht leute ja die ganzen klassen und storage möglichkeiten gibt es ja auch noch du
musst ja das müssen wir uns ja auch noch angucken hier nicht heute im stream aber in
allem der nächste guckt mal meine anwendungen hier sind ja komplett stateless aktuell es sollen
sie im besten fall auch sein in kuba nades ja aber irgendwo müssen die daten ja hin der
einfachste fall ist es gibt irgendwo den datenbank service und du connectest dich dahin liest und
schreibst ein gutes aber manchmal brauchst du auch persistente dateien oder config files oder
config einträge mit environment variabel und sowas also aber spätestens bei dateien fängt
an wo wie bekommst du wie bekommst du files in den container da gibt es auch 1000 varianten von
clusterfile system bis s3 du kannst doch über s3 machen gibt es 1000 varianten und gerade diese
vielfalt und dann die auswahl aus dieser vielfalt was lohnt sich denn jetzt für die neweiligen
anwendungszweil anwendungsfall ja das ist das ist moment dies ist glaube ich nicht die landkarte
die ich kenne doch das ist die landkarte ich kenne ja die ist wirklich nice
ja und das ist bei weitem nicht alles was da drin steht wenn ich reingucke gibt es viele
sagen es ist vieles weil ich noch nie davon gehört habe und auch einiges was hier noch
fehlt also da den überblick zu behalten was es alles gibt und dann das passende auszuwählen
für den anwendungsfall den man hat das ist fast das schwierigste an der ganzen kompanie das
geschichte und was man ehrlicherweise auch sagen muss was auch schwieriger ist als mit vms ist
so ich meine ich habe jetzt hier drei pots laufen alles schön und gut aber wenn dann mal
irgendwas nicht läuft in so einem kompanie das klasse da rauszufinden warum da jetzt also mal
so eine anwendung zu die banken in so einem kompanien das klasse da ist gar nicht mal so
einfach im prinzip könnt ihr eigentlich nur folgendes machen logs für den container konnte
euch angucken so viel mehr die bakt möglichkeiten habt ihr nicht es gibt noch die möglichkeit sich
rein zu connecten in den container das können wir uns können wir uns auch gleich angucken also man
kann ja mit docker was ist docker exek minus it ubuntu bin wesch also wir machen das mal docker
beispiel ja ich krieg das immer nicht aus dem kopf hin was habe ich verkehrt gemacht docker exek
an den docker run docker run und wenn er schon läuft doch er exek wenn er schon läuft doch er
exek kann man sich ja in kontent kann man sich haben in lokale docker container rein verbinden
das gleiche gibt es auch gibt es auch cube ctl exek oder kann man sich versuchen in weiß ich
habe aus dem kopf überhaupt nicht wird es funktioniert kann man sich versuchen rein
zu connecten in die container wenn es da zum beispiel eine shell gibt und so was
das minus minus kommandok die haben aber die haben aber aktuell keine shell aber nicht dass
du trotz ist es trotzdem schwierig so was so was zu debuggen also da muss ich sagen das ist immer
noch wenn du so eine vm hast wurde dich rein connecten kannst und da dann rum wurschteln
kannst drinnen angenehmer so wirklich rauszufinden wo ist der fehler und zu gucken ok warum
funktioniert jetzt die namensauflösung nicht und so was also so ein container deployment zu
debuggen finde ich persönlich eine ganze ecke anspruchsvoller mit dazu gemacht anspruchsvoller
als eine vm wo was drinne läuft heißt die frage wo kommen deine locks raus deine locks sind ja
wahrscheinlich da nicht lokal in dem container sondern auf irgendeiner lock aggregierungs
loki oder irgendwas oder lock sammel plattform oder elastix und was gibt es denn da alles mir
fällt jetzt bloß loki ein von dem was ich verwenden würde kibana gibt es da noch und und zeugs jenkins
nicht jenkins ist kein lock lock sammel plattform wenn das ist das falsche was ich hier aufmache
war das nicht gecheckt dass ich hier moment ich macht es reiter ist wieder zu pepega ok
als hat es wieder nicht gecheckt hier max nepos minikube ab ja trust ok wir machen es
minimal dort net anwendung um euch ein paar wo ich noch ein paar sachen zeigen kann hatten
wir hier noch nie rider offen auf der neuen vm ich glaube nicht ob das ist neu ok sekunde da
müssen wir erstmal was einstellen file settings short cuts ja fast fast ein action auch wieder
den standard short cut ok ja ja remove und editor font ja mal wegen jet planes mono soll
mir recht sein ok so jetzt jetzt sieht man ja hier was ja und them pass mal auf leute
flash bang cake wait ich war noch ein bisschen größer so also wir machen es wirklich eine
ganz simple minimale dort net anwendung also hello world vorher nicht wir wollen return
cute chatter name so und dann müssen wir noch so noch einstellen hier war name gleich wir
machen das auch gleich mit environment variablen dass man auch was weiteres lernen kann environment
variablen get so wunderbar reicht gut das ist unser unsere minimal dort net web anwendung
das reicht auch mehr brauchen wir zum testen an der stelle auch nicht reicht voll und ganz
aus wir machen jetzt noch zwei sachen oder besser gesagt eine sache die sehr nützlich ist und zwar
sagen wir noch ich glaube bilder bilder et health checks service et health checks und dann bei
app et ne och fack wie war das map map health checks und zwar das ganze unter slash helft
wisst ihr warum helft und ich helf weil aus irgendwelchen gründen die kubanete leute sich
gedacht haben es ist eine tolle idee das mit z hinten dran zu schreiben wahrscheinlich weil
das andere schon zu oft belegt war oder so keine ahnung worum das herkommt aber die finden es
cooler dass das mit slash helft vielleicht weiß das deck overflow auch warum das so ist
historisch die it comes from google internal best practices ok leute ihr habt es gehört
helft ist google best practice excellent danke google so das ist unsere dotnet anwendung das
war es auch schon mehr brauchen wir nicht was wir jetzt machen müssen ist ein image bauen für
diese dotnet anwendung und das mache ich ganz einfach ich klaue mir den image weil habe ich
nämlich schon vorbereitet kio kundangische für den sab und sorry falls ich irgendjemand übersehen
habe mit subscriptions add docker support linux docker feil das kommt alles weg weil das rider
template kacke ist und jetzt bärm soll ich das noch mal kurz erklären oder wollen wir das docker
feil einfach zur kenntnis nehmen und nicht mehr reingucken kann ich jetzt vielmals arbeits- oder
weiterbildungszeit absetzen ich würde sagen schon wir machen hier schon wichtige wichtige dinger
so weil mit diesem docker feil kann ich jetzt aus meiner dotnet anwendung ein container bauen und
diesen image bauen und dieses image kann ich in eine container registry pushen und auf diese
container registry kann ich dann an der stelle hier von kubernetes drauf zugreifen und meine
eigene anwendung aus meiner eigenen container registry ziehen und nicht mehr aus einer öffentlichen
container registry im internet ja so sieht es aus wir können mal kurz schauen ob mein bild
funktioniert docker bild punkt ich spreche mal kurz ab docker bild minus t cute app schauen wir mal
ist das dann auch fertig gebaut so docker run it's minus minus am cute app jawoll da sind wir
port 80 karl local host also ich habe kein port zweiter geleitet lull p 80 80 cute chatter gibt
es nicht guck mal keiner unsere anwendung hatten back wir brauchen noch wenn wenn die environment
nicht gesetzt ist brauchen wir noch die fall value excellent ok cute app noch mal bilden
keine cute chatters bekannt ok run cute app wunderbar ok das ist unsere absolut
high IQs maximum IQ also bessere web anwendung geht nicht mehr und wenn ich jetzt slash health
mache dann kommt healthy zurück und wenn ich weglasse kommt nichts weil bei google sagt da
muss ein z hinten dran gut das ist unsere web anwendung fertig aus das war es mit c sharp
für heute demnächst wieder mehr hier test machen das nächste mal wobei man keine test braucht wenn
man immer fehlerfreien code schreibt da braucht man keine doku keine tests und keine kommentare
weil es geht ja eh also sagen wir unsere unsere unsere unsere anwendung und jetzt müssen wir
diese anwendung pushen in unsere lokale container registry ich habe hier schon mal in weißer
voraussicht mein kubanet ist gestartet mit insecure registries weil näher von meiner
container registry ist kein gültiges SSL zertifikat als erstes enable wir das mal
enable registry und irgendwann ist es dann durch ich kann euch auch mal zeichnen kubectl get ports
und hier ist die container registry also die addons sind unter der haube auch nur container
warum nicht pots tja muss man mal google fragen wie das sein kann gut und jetzt müssen wir in
diese lokale container registry unsere app pushen das machen wir nicht mit docker ich kann euch
auch sagen warum wir das nicht mit docker machen weil docker es nicht mag wenn die registry kein
gültiges SSL zertifikat hat das muss man das kann man irgendwie konfigurieren bei docker
fragt mich nicht wo also von der idee her würde man würde man das bilden und dann würde man sagen
docker push und dann die registry ja man muss in den in den konfig feier kann man es reinschreiben
aber wir nehmen einfach potman weil potman hat eine konfig option dafür potman ist quasi ein docker
klon von redhead mit ein paar sachen die docker nicht kann und umgedreht so weil jetzt kann man
sagen potman bild und jetzt kommt es darauf an wie man das image nennt damit das ganze funktioniert
warum nicht pot woman fragt mal twitter heute ist heute ist equal payday weißt du das eigentlich
leute equal payday ist heute jetzt da sollte man schon mal potman potwoman wenigstens mal
zumindest für heute umbenen so also damit das ganze funktioniert damit man sein sein image in die in
die lokale container registry pushen kann muss man das taggen und zwar richtig taggen und zwar mit
der ip und mit der ip beziehungsweise dem namen von der container registry und mit dem image wie
das wie das ganze wie das ganze heißen also ich muss mal sagen wie potman bild wie gesagt mit
docker geht das auch wenn es gültiges zertifikat vor der registry hat also potman bild 192 wobei
wir machen es anders wir machen das wir machen wir machen den script kommt wir sind wir sind mal
super ordentlich wir machen bild punkt sh bin bash registry gleich hoffe ich schreibe das jetzt
nicht registry gleich mini cube ip auf port 5000 läuft die registry das weiß ich weil ich nach
geguckt habe und wir können auch so was wie ein tag hinten angeben vielleicht vielleicht gar nicht
so blöd wenn man tag hinten angeben so und jetzt kommt das was wir an potman kommandos ausführen
nämlich potman bild minus t registry also in dem fall die ip und der port und der port name von
der app und jetzt können wir noch einen tag hinten dran machen so und wenn das fertig ist
können wir sagen potman push und das muss ich mir jetzt kopieren weil ich das aus dem kopf nicht
weiß minus minus tls verify gleich falls und dann funktioniert das auch alles über htp
beziehungsweise auch mit ungültigen zertifikaten und jetzt hier den gleichen krempel ich habe
mich auch einen punkt vergessen so wenn ich das script jetzt richtig gebaut habe dann sollte
er uns jetzt ein container image bilden und in die registry pushen was habe ich denn verkehrt
gemacht potman bild minus t registry gut er hat ich habe den tag vergessen anzugeben ok ja also
1.0.0 hi iq app ok jetzt ok er baut und ihr seht es sieht fast aus wie bei docker nur dass es jetzt
potman ist wieso der code war richtig funktioniert ohne jegliche änderung
so image ist gepusht nice und was ich jetzt machen kann ist folgendes ich trage jetzt an
der stelle einfach ein lokal host ich kann an der stelle jetzt lokal host verwenden weil die
registry innerhalb des kubernetes clusters läuft es funktioniert an der stelle lokal host 5000
slash cute app doppelpunkt versionsnummer 1.0.0 und jetzt werdet ihr feststellen ich zeige es
mal watch karl keckel ihr seht hier das ist der aktuelle service der da läuft das ist noch der
hallo welt service das ist noch nicht noch nicht unsere web anwendung was ist köln minus s glaube
ich für weniger output genau so das ist noch nicht unser unser web anwendung ich habe jetzt in dem
fall hier in unserer in unserem manifest aus dem kubernetes manifest das image ausgetauscht was
ich als anwendung verwenden will vorher hatte ich hier diese traffic hello world ab und jetzt
habe ich unsere eigene anwendung da rein gepackt die wir die wir vorher als container image
verpackt haben und in diese registry gepusht haben und wenn jetzt alles funktioniert ich hoffe es
mal wir machen hier wir machen hier parallel noch mal ein get pods dass wir nämlich sehen wenn
es fehler gibt wo ich das studio muss mal kurz weg und jetzt sage ich apply und vorher hier
wenn ich immer raus apply so alte container werden neue container werden gestartet alte
container werden gesteckt ja ja ja zack ich habe jetzt quasi neue anwendung deploit ohne
das request kaputt gegangen sind zwischendurch wie euch vielleicht aufgefallen ist das natürlich
schon nice gelb aber das war weg also wir wissen jetzt ja dass mit dem image funktioniert so
jetzt haben wir hier unsere eigene anwendung drauf laufen jetzt brauchen wir noch ein paar
andere geschichten dass das ordentlich funktioniert weil aktuell ist es so und um euch das mal zu
demonstrieren beziehungsweise dass man ich zeige so mal dass man sich besser vorstellen kann machen
wir mal 6 machen wir mal 69 container ihr werdet feststellen gleich gibt es wieder jede menge
container während es aufbaut wir machen mal eine ein dirty hack in unserem build script
den sehe ich hier nehme ich gerade drüben dass ich das auch aus anderen verzeichnissen ausführen
kann so abbild und jetzt machen wir mal eine neue versionsnummer von der app ja also zum
beispiel okay ich ändere ich ändere der form halber auch noch was ja es gibt der west version
1.0.1 von dieser app und zwar ist es cute chatter ja ich will ich will hier wobei irgendwas cute
cute chatter ist es jetzt okay schreibt man das überhaupt so cute test cute chatter also es ist
jetzt noch noch mehr alles und das will ich jetzt einchecken also ich baue ein neues image
draus aus der anwendung mit diesem mit diesem fix drin image version 1.0.1 pusht das wieder
in die registry so und jetzt apply ich das und was wird jetzt passieren leute es wird nichts
passieren es wird nichts passieren weil es hat sich ja nichts geändert es hat sich ja nichts
geändert warum sind meine pots eigentlich alle pending da unten ich glaube ich habe zu viele
kann es sein dass ich mit den ressourcen am limit bin dass das meine dass ich zu viele pots habe
okay moment wir skalieren es mal runter auf was sinnvolles auf 10 oder so
so also wenn ich das jetzt applye und wieder karl mache werdet ihr vielleicht feststellen es
ist immer noch die alte message warum na ja weil die versionsnummer die hier drin steht immer noch
1.0 ist ich will ja 1.0.1 haben so und jetzt wird euch gleich ein problem auffallen wenn ich das
jetzt applye dann wird er updaten dann wird er updaten von dieser von dem tag 1.0.0 auf
1.0.1 und wenn ihr mal genau guckt was er hier unten macht wird euch vielleicht was auffallen der
startet neue container und lässt dann die alten container löst dann die alten container aber euch
wird auffallen das zeug ist relativ schnell ready das zeug ist relativ schnell ready das komisch
und das ist aber auch doof weil wenn jetzt im falschen momenten ein request rankommt könnte
es ja theoretisch sogar sein dass der request auf dem container landet der noch gar nicht richtig
gestartet ist das heißt wir müssen jetzt nicht nur den container starten sondern wir müssen
auch checken ob der container bereit ist ob der container bereit ist machen wir mit den health
checks hier drinnen wenn du eine fehlerhafte version deploys ist ja quasi achso jaja jaja ach
das ist eine gute idee das kann ich auch zeigen das kann ich auch zeigen guckt mal ich skaliere
jetzt mal ein bisschen runter auf sechs stück erst mal wir werfen keine exception ich trage
einfach eine tag ein den es nicht gibt also ich gehe jetzt mal kurz runter auf sechs das sieht
man so mal angenommen ich sage jetzt hier nehmen mal image version 1.0.2 die es noch nicht gibt
und ich applye das jetzt dann werdet ihr feststellen der versucht es zu applyen aber
er image pull oder macht nicht weiter und die alten laufen weiter das heißt ich habe obwohl
ich eine fehlerhafte konfig haben das ist wirklich auch eine coole sache an kompanien ist obwohl ich
eine fehlerhafte konfig habe ein weiterhin funktionierenden service zwar die alte version
aber egal ich meine besser als er ist kaputt kaputt wäre glaube ich das blödeste was was
an der stelle passieren könnte so wenn ich das als wieder rückgängig mache mal wieder version
eins rein sache play dann checkt er das ganze auch und er geht wieder auf sechs replikas hoch
also ich habe angeheben ich möchte sechs davon laufen lassen und das ist wirklich cool und das
im großen stil ist eigentlich der grund schlechthin also dieses solche features in der richtung ist
nicht explizit dieses ist der grund schlechthin warum kuba netis sich überhaupt so durchgesetzt
hat du kannst halt wunderbar deinen ganzen workload über mehrere notes skalieren und du kannst
relativ gut ausfallfrei deine software managen damit das eigentlich der hauptsächliche grund
warum warum kuba netis so beliebt ist oder sich auch so durchgesetzt hat gab ja noch ein paar
andere pro andere dinge es gab dann zwischenzeitlich mal docker swarm was ja immer noch gibt aber
kaum jemand benutzt dann gibt es noch ein paar andere geschichten wo mir grad nichts ein gibt
noch no mad gibt es noch das ist aber glaube ich auch noch mehr mit vms dabei fällt jemand
nehmen eine gute kuba netis alternative ein hat er genau nicht auch mal den versuch mit lxd
gestartet irgendwie sowas zu bauen was keiner haben wollte mesos mesos gibt es noch richtig
apache war das apache openshift wobei ist auch ein schiff noch deutlich mehr nicht noch deutlich
mehr dabei dass du da auch ne moment das ist nicht openshift das ist das openshift also
openshift ist die telekom cloud das weiß ich die telekom cloud ist aber das heißt ja nicht
dass es das heißt ja nicht dass es schlecht sein muss wie heißt das andere wo noch vms und so
dabei sind open stack meine ich ich meine open stack und die telekom cloud ist open stack
darum war das nicht openshift open stack meine ich genau ja richtig richtig so siehts aus so
was wollte ich was wollte ich denn jetzt noch machen ja also ihr habt jetzt ja gesehen es
sind jetzt ganz viele services neu gestartet worden aber die dinger waren sofort ready das
will man ja nicht das heißt wir haben ja hier einen health check definiert service
fabric ok mir fällt schon außer kopernet ist gar nicht gar nicht mehr so viel ein so man kann
jetzt an der stelle sagen hier wo man wo man replikas einträgt kann ich auch noch glaube ich
sagen strategy type rolling ich glaube rolling update glaube ich ist sogar der default da bin
ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher rolling update und dann kann man das braucht man eigentlich
gar nicht ja da kann man dann noch so was sagen wie max unavailable eins und max max
search eins oder man kann auch zwei in dem fall so kann man jetzt einstellen wie er
ab updates machen soll also rolling update ist glaube ich relativ selbsterklärend
und wobei das ja noch nicht alles ist was wir machen müssen und hier kann man jetzt
auswählen wie er vorgehen soll beim rolling upgrade also von diesen sechs replikas wie viele
dürfen nicht erreichbar sein während dem update und wie viele dürfen mehr da sein als target also
mit diesen settings würde folgendes passieren er könnte zum beispiel einen neuen container
erzeugen schon im vorfeld bevor er den alten stoppt und dann können den alten stoppen so dass
kurzzeitig fünf nur laufen und das zwischenzeitlich kurz auch mal sieben laufen können was ja wichtig
ist weil bei einem update müssen ja neue container gestartet werden alte container gestoppt werden
das ist halt die frage wie man das macht man kann natürlich auch hier mehr eintragen wenn
man damit dacor ist dass auch mal von diesen replikas weniger laufen hiermit kann man das
quasi ein bisschen feintunen wie man dieses updates wie man dieses update durchführen
will wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt sag wie ging das jetzt die deployment cube cube rollout cube
ctl rollout restart wobei ich brauche ich gar nicht ich kann jetzt einfach apply machen doch
nicht unchanged ok cube ctl rollout restart deployment das sieht man jetzt macht er das
halt entsprechen dieser policy das maximum einer eben hier immer abgecreated wird aber
wenn ich jetzt hier zum beispiel version runter runter gehe auf version eins sach apply dann
seht ihr ok der erzeugt zwei neue und er stoppt immer kann auch immer ein zwei austauschen
immer ein mehr und ein weniger kann man das kann man so ein bisschen ein bisschen feintunen was
er was er machen darf so was aber viel wichtiger ist wir brauchen noch health checks weil ihr
seht jedes mal wenn der container gestartet ist er sofort ready das stimmt ja gar nicht der
container ist gar nicht sofort ready der muss ja auch erst mal starten die web anwendung muss
starten ich mein das geht schnell ja mein pot man run cute cute app also das hieß ja
irgendwie anders was ich so ihr seht so container startet schnell ist mal exemplarisch lokal bei
mir mit docker der startet schnell aber es ist trotzdem eine halbe sekunde wo der container
gestartet ist aber noch nicht bereit ist requests anzunehmen und es könnte ja auch durchaus
länger dauern okay keine frage so und dafür gibt es solche sachen wie ready probe und life
oder leifnis probe und readiness probe das muss man das muss man abgucken wo das hin muss unter
portz muss unterhalb von portz also dahin muss das an der stelle
als wer cringe das kann ich dir nicht erzählen habe ich keine große erfahrung drin ich würde
mal sagen mit datenbank migrations du willst die postgres version updaten oder was also willst
nicht deine datenbank intern die struktur updaten du willst die datenbank version updaten oder wie
das eigentlich erwarten dass deine anwendung sowohl mit der alten als auch mit der neuen
version funktioniert weil ansonsten ansonsten wäre das easy du updatest zuerst die datenbank
wenn du die datenbank version updaten willst du updatest zuerst die datenbank dann die anwendung
und dann ist gut das schema ok du willst so was wie eine datenbank migration oder so haben das
eine gute frage habe ich keine erfahrung mit wie man das gescheit synchronisiert
gibt es bestimmt irgendwelche super tollen best practice sachen für aber ich kann ihr
da nix nix sinnvolles zu sagen ich kann mit höchstens was zusammen reiben was mir da so
auf dem stegreif einfällt aber ich weiß wenn du das schema updatest dann erweiterst du das
schema ja in der regel oder machst du das schema incompatibel also geht die alte anwendung noch
mit der neuen schema version oder nicht wahrscheinlich nicht ja wenn das so wenn das so voneinander
abhängt müsste ich mir gedanken zu machen kann ich dir so vielleicht an der chat ahnung wir haben
hier viele 5 hat cloud native kubernetes 6 herz vielleicht fällt da jemand was zu ein
wahrscheinlich kommen die leute jetzt wahrscheinlich kommen die leute jetzt an und sagen ha ha null gar
keine sql datenbanken mehr verwenden sondern einfach nur noch cloud native data basis wobei
das halt wobei das halt nicht realistisch ist das ist dann wenn du die falschen leute was sie kommen
dann immer mit so was so ja warum verwendest du auch nicht cloud technologie in kürze bescheuern
wer definiert was cloud technologie sachen ist und was nicht also das ist das ist was du hast
zweiergründer ist ein sehr praktischer und realer anwendungsfall und darauf gibt es bestimmt auch
eine gute lösung habe ich aber keine erfahrungen mit kann ich dir gerade nicht sagen zu also das
naheliegendste ist natürlich du musst sicherstellen dass die alte anwendung auch mit dem neuen schema
funktioniert also dass du kannst du darfst das schema zwar erweitern aber das ist nicht
inkompatibel zur alten anwendung machen dann funktioniert es dann ist easy dann kannst du
zuerst die datenbank updaten und dann die anwendung und wenn das nicht so ist fällt jetzt so spontan
nicht so viel ein weil da müsstest du ja sicherstellen dass du irgendwie so einen so
einen rolling update macht so die datenbank updaten dann wobei es halt je nach datenbank auch so ist
dass du gar keine unterschiedlichen datenbank anspricht sondern alle datenbanken in dem cluster
über halt ein ein ein connection string wenn du so willst dass du gar nicht explizit sagen kannst
ich will jetzt nur auf diese ja da gibt es bestimmt coole möglichkeiten zu bis jetzt hatte ich das
muss ich mich mit diesem problem noch nicht beschäftigen wenn es soweit ist sag ich dir
bescheid ich würde einfach sagen ist job der dba es kümmert dich nicht drum dass sie das machen
sag einfach nicht mein problem easy ja aber kommen wir mal zur container geschichte zurück damit
ich mitbekomme wann meine anwendung wirklich gestartet ist gibt es readiness probes und es
gibt man dieses autocomplete alter ist es schlecht man leifnis probe gibt es das eine ist wenn
der container ready also wenn der container gestartet ist zum ersten mal und das zweite
ist ob der container noch weiterhin funktioniert und ich copy paste mir das jetzt hier raus aus
dem beispiel weil ich keinen bock habe das noch mal alles zu tippen so sieht das ganze dann aus
aber gibt sogar eine hilfe dazu der guckt ob der ob der container ready ist und der guckt ob der
container noch am leben ist und wenn diese das ist der unterschied wenn diese leifnis probe
fehlschlägt dann restartet kubernetes den container kann auch sehr praktisch sein falls die anwendung
nicht komplett krascht sondern intern bloß in so einem zustand gerät dass sie nicht mehr richtig
funktioniert also leifnis probe startet kubernetes im zweifelsfall den container neu und hier kann
unter anderem dieser ready check entscheiden wann das denn in den load balancer aufgenommen wird es
gibt auch startup probe ja aber das braucht man in der regel nicht genau so und wenn ich das jetzt
applye dann werdet ihr vielleicht gleich was feststellen guckt mal das geht jetzt deutlich
langsamer seht ihr das das das geht jetzt deutlich langsamer alles und warum weil er halt immer
fünf sekunden wartet bis das ding auch wirklich am leben ist also der wartet fünf sekunden macht
dann diesen health check ob es am leben seht es dauert deutlich länger aber jetzt haben wir den
großen vorteil jetzt gehen keine requests mehr keine neuen requests mehr verloren also wenn
ihr einen ganz ungünstigen moment erwischt dass ihr gerade weitergeleitet worden seid auf den
server und der wird gerade weg gestartet oder so dann kann es sein dass man immer noch ein
fehler kriegt aber es verschwindet gering und das kann ich euch jetzt auch zeigen ich mache mal ein
benchmark ok ich mache ich mache eine neue version wir gehen wieder zurück zu cute cute chatter ich
mache ich mache eine neue version 1.0.2 von unserem container pusht das in die registry update die
container version und jetzt passt mal auf ich mache ein benchmark hey wenn man 30 sekunden
oder mal länger eine minute aber eine minute eine minute holle pulle requests auf diesen service
ich fange jetzt an und jetzt mache ich das update apply wir können wir können nebenbei
nebenbei zugucken cute pots ja ihr seht die pots werden neu gestartet und werden hinzugehnen
hinzugenommen und alles latest funktioniert nicht apply läuft immer nur dann wenn sich das manifest
geändert hat latest funktioniert nicht es gibt tricks dass es mit latest funktioniert aber
das starrer mich funktioniert das mit latest nicht so unser rolling update ist fertig und jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt ob requests verloren gegangen sind das läuft noch ok irgendwie das zum irgendwie
spackt es rum wir warten mal kurz die minute ab es spammt es spammt immer noch heftig so requests
und guckt mal wir haben eine millionen requests gemacht und nur und jetzt halt euch aus von einer
millionen requests sind nur während diesem rolling update 39 oder 40 requests mal als nicht
erreichbar zurückgekommen von einer millionen requests 40 und wir haben unsere anwendung
geupdatet im hintergrund ich weiß wir hatten mal so einen krassen manager dude der gesagt hätte
jetzt 40 requests dann sollten wir uns jetzt mal auf die konzentrieren die nicht funktioniert
haben haben wir vielleicht logs wo wir die bangen können warum diese requests fehlgeschlagen sind
aber ich glaube das ist eine ganz gute ausbeute von einer millionen requests 40 requests fehl
geschlagen und das während wir unsere anwendung geupgradet haben also das ist schwierig hinzukriegen
anderweitig ja
hättest du 100 prozent wenn du kein crawling update du meinst ein rolling update machen
würdest die rolling update ist das beste was man machen kann du hast als auswahl sollst
nur recreate ich bin den haus gebrauche ist das nix es gibt so verrückte leute auf youtube die
haben drei kubernetes cluster daheim ist unsinnig und was man an der stelle auch noch mal dazu sagen
muss wir haben jetzt hier in kubernetes cluster selbst erstellt und verwalten den kubernetes
cluster selbst normalerweise musst du dich mit so grundlegenden sachen wie skalierung und so gar
nicht großartig auseinandersetzen wenn du managet cluster also nicht einfach nur managet cluster so
nen so wenn du den autopilot cluster von google beispielsweise wenn es da brauchst du nur noch
deployments machen damit müssen wir uns auch noch beschäftigen die nächsten tage
oder versions updates versions updates von kubernetes und solche geschichte da musst du dich nicht mit
beschäftigen wenn du managet cluster verwendet also vieles von diesen basic sachen musst du gar
nicht selbst machen zumal ich meine wenn du den benchmark jetzt ausführst sind dann alle 100% kann
schauen wir mal ich lass den noch mal laufen es kann durchaus sein dass die ein oder weil meine
cpu ist ja auch voll am anschlag dass die ein oder anderen request einfach nicht nicht richtig
durchgehen also managet cluster kümmern sich um versions updates von kubernetes und so was schon
da hat man viel arbeit nicht mehr was aber eigentlich auch ganz gut ist weil ganz ehrlich da
hängt halt sehr viel so lowlevel kram dran wo es schwierig ist das alles das alles richtig zu
machen und was auch ein gewisses tiefgreifendes knowhow erfordert alle staub ja das waren die
control set ich habe kein control set gemacht ich habe terminal auf und zu gemacht ja jetzt
habe ich eine millionen responses und zwar alles 200 ja also wir hatten tatsächlich 40 request
verlust in unserem upgrade gibt schlimmeres oder von eine millionen requests ok chat wie
hat es euch bis jetzt gefallen kubernetes stells wie gesagt ich bin ich ich bin selbst nicht ich
bin ja selbst nicht der super super oberkombiniertes checker aber ich glaube so mit lokaler registry
und so was hier das war schon ganz cool dann lasst uns doch jetzt noch mal kurz eine viertelstunde
überlegen was wir als nächstes machen also als nächstes eine sache die mir eingefallen ist ja
environment variablen genau so volume secrets manager das will ich unbedingt zeichen mit
letzten crypt lokal dns challenge na service mesh das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen zu advanced
dann vielleicht irgendwann mal ja und ends backends traffic gibt näher bisher ja ok
geht aber ich finde den namen so das ist da hat man eigentlich was recht logisches also was
naheliegendes so nach dem motto man checkt seine config in geht ein wieder super cool benannt
dazu kommt da natürlich aber auch noch so dinge wie automatische tests und also man könnte man
könnte ja zum beispiel sogar solche dinge machen wie ganz abgedreht weiterspinnen man könnte ja
zum beispiel sagen ok man hat noch eine test suite für diese test suite fürs jetzt super krasse
dort net anwendung und man lässt es dann irgendwie automatisch noch bilden und lässt die tests
durchlaufen und lässt sich dinger machen dann automatisch noch auf irgendeinem ce server das
image bauen dass man das nicht lokal machen mussten was in der richtung gibt ja gibt ja viele viele
dinge man kann ganz abgedrehte sachen machen ja also irgendwann was wir uns auf jeden fall noch
angucken ist das finde ich persönlich eine coole sache weil du damit weil du hiermit kannst du
solche manifest erstellen in pyson zum beispiel finde ich persönlich eine super geschichte ist
eigentlich aufer kill und komplett unsinnig für vieles aber ich persönlich finde es sehr nice
weil man halt zum beispiel so sachen definieren kann guck hier hier hier kann man zum beispiel
sagen hier kubeservice load balancer kubedeployment also das was wir eben im manifest
definiert haben kann man hier drinnen ja ich weiß man kann auch hellen und so was verwenden
ich persönlich würde dann aber fast sagen mir persönlich ist das hier finde ich den ansatz hier
cooler weil man dann vollständige programmier sprache und ich mache halt lieber das im source
code als irgendwelche jamme files und description files und so bauen also das ist cool ja hellen
müssen müssen wir uns aber der vollständigkeit halber auf jeden fall angucken weil fast jedes
zweite tutorial heißt ja in hellen repo enden und ausführen zum beispiel secret manager secret
manager sagt das auch customize habe ich keine ahnung von kein plan vielleicht können wir uns
irgendwann auch mal terraform noch in kombination mit dem kubernetes provider angucken habe ich
jetzt auch noch nicht gemacht ja dann gucken wir uns natürlich noch google cloud managt kubernetes
und auto autopilot an das ist der eigentliche grund warum ich mich in den letzten tagen wieder
ein bisschen mehr damit beschäftigt habe weil ich weiß dass bei meinem neuen arbeitgeber google
cloud mit wahrscheinlich managt kubernetes oder autopilot cluster vielleicht darf sogar ich mir
aussuchen was ich haben will einsetzen wer das heißt da muss ich ein bisschen gucken
metal lb ich habe keine ahnung was das ist ich kenne kong kong ist auch so ein
lautballon kein lautballon son api gateway ist das harambe
ich habe keine ahnung was es mir sagen soll ehrlich gesagt netwerk lautballon
sampler mit dem kubernetes using standard routing protokolls was ja selbstverständlich
da habe ich ja ganz vergessen das müssen wir noch mal ja prometheus
matrix ja matrix auch nachher natürlich da müssen wir uns noch seit konteine angucken
für so monitoring und logs also ihr seht schon die einfache die bild in kubernetes sachen die
sind an sich recht easy ja kommt man recht schnell mit aber das ist ein loch ohne boden was da alles
dran hängt dann ja voliums voliums ja haben wir ja schon
und das was da dran ist wirklich ein fast ohne boden so bild in sachen den kubernetes jammel
eintragen apply ja kein ding aber dieses ganze zeug was hier noch dabei kommt das ist halt
extrem viel was es da gibt ja autodiscovery ja das sollten wir uns auch mal angucken ja
ja genau ne traffic prominent engine x ich bin ich bin team engine x ich habe traffic
selbst auch schon verwendet ich muss sagen ganz im ernst ich bleibe bei engine x ich benutze
card event super simpel sein muss traffic von hand konfigurieren ist eh abfuck und traffic macht
halt in so einem umfeld hier schon irgendwie sinn weil es auch viele service discovery funktionen
ganz ehrlich aber es ist so easy in engine x ingress zu machen warum soll ich da traffic
verwenden glaubt glaubt er welchen bogen erst mal drum machen ja schreiben wir noch mal
dass wir uns das dann auch grafisch angucken können dahinter wenn euch noch was einfällt
könnt ihr ruhig auch im nächsten stream schreiben da können wir uns das dann angucken also wir
machen jetzt auf jeden fall erst mal weiter mit third manager und environments und volumes und
sowas im nächsten stream ist ach du scheiße das ist nicht nice so nice jetzt fängt diese
spotting scheiße schon in deutschland an oder was hat er seine adresse geleakt oder oder was war da
mega für den arsch mann ok leute ich wann machst du tiktok sein ja ich macht ich werd
krasser cooper natives cloud native influencer auf auf tiktok leute es ist fast 22 ich muss jetzt
eh mal ins bett außerdem muss ich mal ganz dringend kacken also das wird eine serie ja
nicht unbedingt am stück nicht unbedingt am stück jetzt kooper näht es jeden stream bis
wir mit allem durch den immer mal wieder machen wir machen wir ja ok leute wir sehen uns dann bis
dann see you